[Music]
hey you guys happy Halloween retreat
look it look it Tom with it looks like I
kind of love this jacket you do you look
like you look like you Darth Vader after
you take his helmet off and it yeah you
look just like that and look we even
like excellent so as you can see you
know in honor of this is just a little
intro we're doing the bulk of the show
actually we filmed somewhere else and we
had a Sean and Eric on so we'll get to
that in a little bit but look we have
like a little different background this
is actually my office I put like all
these Halloween decorations which are
actually just my regular decorations cuz
I don't you know every day is Halloween
you know how that [ __ ] goes yeah we
decided to get a little bit dressed up
for the intro and you know do Halloween
[ __ ] cuz it's a special Halloween
special right now these are my regular
clothes they are yeah well like I said
we didn't need like to buy costumes or
anything like that our our whole closets
is just full of [ __ ] like this it's like
stepping into a black hole black I know
we got goth problems we are from pants
blacker than this shirt and tones and
shades of black cuz there are there are
many yeah and really that's the way that
I recognize my clothes it's like yeah
they're all black but they're all
different shades of black yeah so yeah
we have so we know it's kind of
exaggeration we do have I do have like
military colors and things like that too
and you know you have colored t-shirts I
have a brown shirt and a red shirt yeah
and that's about it
the rest of the stuff is black but like
I said the main bulk of the show like
the middle portion we just recorded us
kind of you know reading a bunch of
stories that guy sent in and shot at
Eric we
then we kind of went off on some
tangents we talked about nightmares we
had we talked about various paranormal
experiences we had other scary [ __ ] that
happened I I want to say like at the
outset we got like a really lot of good
stories there were a couple of them that
I had to leave out just because they
were too long I mean this story or this
you know episode is ended up being like
I don't know how long it's gonna be when
I edit it all together but it's like at
least you know two and a half three
hours long which is fine because it's a
Halloween special but you know some of
the stories we just kind of you know we
started reading them and they were like
okay well this is just too long we're
just gonna take this one out so I really
really apologize if you sent me a story
and I didn't use it but some of them
were just too long and we wanted to kind
of keep it keep the show like why don't
we short stories pretty good about woman
being haunted by a dead husband yeah I
know I really liked that about an hour
and a half worth worth of read it's just
not impossible it's not possible to put
that in the show yeah that's what I mean
it's like so you know I fell really bad
as I wanted to read everything was a
couple other ones I had to leave out
changes cuz they were really long but
you know that's that story out of dad I
don't be put out in short story and put
it on audiobook yeah it should yeah you
should actually I gotta sell that yeah
but so like I said at the beginning what
we're gonna do here and if you want to
hear me reading like some little
fragments of my couple of my fictional
stories then I'm just gonna put that I
just read a couple by myself you know
it's just a few minutes and that'll be
like at the very end of the show so if
you want to like stay tuned for that
then that's where that will be other
than that let's do a couple of shout
outs and then I have one personal
experience a story that a girl named
Dana sent in and it kind of just came in
right under the wire and we didn't have
time to do it while Shauna and Eric
we're here so I said okay well we'll
just do it in the intro and you know so
then her story will be covered too
because I really liked it so let's see
what are our what are our shout outs our
last movie review was Lucy offal she's
the beyond and I was very excited that I
finally got to do a Lucci offal chain
movie also I wanted to give a shout out
to Dan who's one of our patrons and he
actually increased his support so thank
you very much for that I also want to
give a shout out to knothead studios who
gave us a very generous PayPal donation
yes
day so thank you very good drop like 50
bucks they did yes and I was like we
really really appreciate that and like I
said you know we try our best to make
the shows enjoyable for you guys you
know we and now we do three shows a week
so any so any help is appreciated like I
said if you want to go to our patreon
page or go to our PayPal yeah we're up
to about 400 we are you and that's like
that's only like what 15 20 so I think
it's 38 3 most of our patrons are heavy
hitters they're really helping us out
giving us 20 give us $30 a month thing
they do yeah yeah someone gave us 40 a
month that's awesome yeah I know it's
amazing and really I like I said
anything
you know we appreciate anything even
even if you can't like give us any
financial support even just sharing the
show we're telling other people about it
share subscribe yeah anything like that
you know if you just share it on Twitter
share it on whatever it's like you know
that really does it yeah so that helps a
lot too if you would like to contribute
it that way yeah you can plug this to
try to get us as guest is on your
favorite show people was asking us to be
guest anyway just something shows a
little small yeah but I you know I like
to do them anyways and it's like you
know cuz you never know who might hear
that you know that might not have heard
we were on a radio show in LA one time
and I think we were the only people
listening that was amazing that mean
that was us and Steve Merrill was on the
show with us too is parapsychologist
which most of you will know if you
listen to us regularly that was the
worst show of all time and it seemed
like they were very excited to get us on
and they seemed very professional but
then when the show started there were
like three or four hosts yeah and they
were they sounded either drunk or really
stupid fret bro - yeah they didn't even
really ask us any pertinent they didn't
ask they started talking about sports
and I was just kind of like are we even
here like let's go I said two sentences
the whole time I think zoom - it's like
I don't even know if I said anything and
it's like I I thought maybe they've got
high and they forgot we were there or
something like that was like the very
influence of something yeah definitely
it was either stupidity or stupid
stupidity plus some other substances but
yeah that was a very weird
like a local plus I see masks
adrenochrome except not as fun as that
sounds so let's do this story that Dana
said and this is apparently it sounded
from the way she wrote it this sounded
like a personal experience that happened
to her probably about 20 years ago and
you'll appreciate this because it was
kind of had kind of a gothy flair so I
thought that's kind of nice that we're
putting it right here at the beginning
when we're all dressed up in [ __ ] so
here we go this is Dana's story as I
said in the main part I don't want to
use anybody's last names just in case
they get mad at me so that's what I'm
doing so here's her story my head was
hanging out of the window nostrils and
hair full of wind my eyes were closed
relaxed my mouth smiling I took in the
thrill of the night do you want a clove
my gothy stormy friend Amanda asked
driving us forward yes I do I've known
Amanda for over 20 years but on this
night our friendship was new I called
her my stormy friend because although
we've only known each other through
phone calls in most recent years at one
time when we both occupied the same
physical space we seemed to manifest
very crazy very intense storms we've
laughed about it often and joked that we
haven't lived in the same place for so
long because the world simply could not
handle it that cracked me up very much
yeah they're on that chilly fall night I
opened my eyes but before accepting the
gift I looked up to take in the fullness
of a misty moon bringing my head and my
attention back into the car I lit my
cigarette with her already burning one
and we let them both fill the air with
thick fragrant smoke we pulled into a
long swerving dirt driveway our
destination was to hang out and walk a
track located amidst a nearby playground
the middle was filled with old rusty
contraptions for kids the dusty track
surrounded the still in silent swings
beyond that in three of the four
directions were Hills and which perched
thickets of pine trees to others as we
parked and got out of her old Camaro
dressed all in black we must have looked
like two dark specters approaching the
dirt circle however there were no others
the playground was silent except for the
soft whisperings of the wind creeping
across the land the only light besides
the moon was a single lamppost
illuminating a small portion of the
track nearby was a set of picnic tables
where we decided to stop for yet another
smoke break
we sat atop the tables talking about
many things anxious
learn each other's past experiences our
life dreams and our favorite subject
spooky things before we had a chance to
walk we noticed the headlights of
another car swiftly speeding down the
road a trail of dust followed behind as
it got closer we realized it was a
police car it parked beside us and the
officer got out he walked towards us
with a calm stride and with a kind
manner explained to us that we couldn't
be out there past sundown of course we
said it was cool and that we'd be
leaving satisfied with our words he
wished us goodnight and got back into
his vehicle we watched his taillights
disappear in the distance with a small
degree of disappointment we got
ourselves together and followed however
when we got to the end of the road we
saw the entrance sign it indicated that
the playground was closed after dark but
that the track was always open we also
recalled that a relative had previously
told us about the place and said they
had walked there at night determined not
to go home and using some kind of weird
misguided logic but as long as we were
walking the path our presence there
should be ok we turned the car around
and headed back again we exited the car
but immediately approached the track we
had to avoid a not quite dried mud
puddle right at the edge everything else
had dried from the last week's rain but
this one had been too big and too deep
we stepped over it and on to the
circular trail sue began our spiraling
walk the conversation continued with
each word directing our attention more
and more to each other around us the
shadows fluttered and shifted in the
depth of the trees we took no notice one
lap around we approached the one light
looming above the track at the same
instance we peered at the ground
confused at first we soon recognized in
the dead center of the spotlight was an
arrow drawn in the dirt
we stopped abruptly and then continued
forward slowly with curiosity and
caution our eyes followed the direction
that arrow pointed if there had been any
breeze at all it was for sure gone at
that moment it seemed as if the air
itself had been sucked from the earth as
we both saw hovering in the woods a
small orange light it almost reminded us
of a burning cigarette in fact that's
what we decided it was but it remained
in the same spot the light of it fading
in and out almost rhythmically at a time
when we should have been alarmed or at
least suspicious for some reason we
dismissed this strangeness and continued
on the circular path around we went
again talking laughing
our breath getting more rapid turning
the curves of the circle we turned on
conversation of the topic of music and
started talking about the Cure we talked
about that song boys don't cry I don't
remember much else because as we
approached the lamppost for a second
time the breath was taken from us both
drawn next to the arrow where the words
boys don't cry nervously we began to
look around surely someone must be on
the track listening to us we thought but
how could we have missed them we
couldn't have there was no place to hide
the area surrounding us and the space
before the trees was empty and flat
again I thought there was no place for
anyone to hide with every muscle
stiffening aching with a small shock we
managed to continue on with the
intention of getting to the car just
like in dreams our legs seemed to be
going faster than our mind perceived the
passage of time but I feel like we were
both trying to hold it together trying
hard not to panic finally the car grew
more comfortably in sight there was a
small amount of relief but then we had
to cross over that mud puddle again deep
in the surface of the wet were dog
prints that were much much too big to be
dog prints shocked flooded our systems
and I don't know who said it but one of
us gasped that wasn't there before was
it and the other gave an abrupt no for
an answer there was no hesitation only
immediate and desperate action we
practically ran for the car and as our
feet fled it seemed that behind them
stirred up the cold wind that rapidly
began to build up on itself the
atmosphere came wildly alive and as we
entered the car and shut the door it was
like we were fleeing a hurricane inside
was a sense of false quiet and calm
among the oncoming storm we thought we
heard a long piercing howl pounding the
locks on the doors down Amanda cranked
up the ignition the wind was now
swirling around us as she quickly backed
up through the car and gear and took off
down the road I find it interesting that
as we were leaving that police car was
coming back in we passed each other in
the turbulent night we made no attempt
to stop and were quite sure he was
confirming that we had left the area
that night it rained again the storm
tore on and on it ripped through the
city long after we said goodbye and
headed for our own homes I don't think
either of us slept and I recall neither
of us got any kind of deeper refreshing
sleep for weeks after there were
nightmares neither of us could remember
but we did recall a sense of unease
mostly at night there was that
unsettling
that you weren't alone I would gaze out
of my second-story window and think that
I could see some shadow in the nearby
woods or hear a deep growling mingled
with the wind I thought I could hear the
tapping of nails walking along the
pavement below the shapes were always
those of a big dog
eventually the anxious feeling subsided
and life went on as usual I must add
that a couple days after that happened
and the rain had diminished my curiosity
led me to drive back to that Park in the
daylight it was a clear sunny day crisp
and beautiful like the rain had washed
all things dirty away leaving everything
spotless there were several cop cars
parked with k-9 unit stickers on the
back of them I saw that some officers
were out on the grassy knoll playing
catch and having fun with their German
Shepherd comrades and others were
leading theirs open the hills among the
trees where that light had shined
looking for something I thought to get
out of my car walk up to an officer and
ask questions and it certainly crossed
my mind but in the end I observed for a
while and then just drove away from time
to time that night still crosses my mind
I realize I'll never know what was that
in those woods I guess I don't want to
that's why I didn't ask the question I
do wonder why we responded the way we
did to certain things like not leaving
to begin with and why we weren't more
alarmed by that arrow and that light in
the woods how he shrugged it off and
then and when now I would have run I
think that maybe something was luring us
our minds naturally eased by the flow of
that circle and we walked and that
little warm light that burned
alternately dim and then bright this
story creeped me the [ __ ] out what's
what state did this happen again do was
it mention oh I don't know I don't I
don't think she said actually that was
the south it might have been know what
that was what do you think it was that
was a spirit of Orion that's right well
you know Elvis was known in the south as
being a messiah that was the Mississippi
Messiah yeah all right that he died yeah
rose again as Orion and then Orion got
killed in a in a holdup he's at the pawn
shop that is a change now he's come back
from the dead as a hound dog yeah
ghost of Orion yeah I'm not sure what
what state that took place in you guys
should see a riot once the hell wasn't
in that documentary Orion the man who
would be king or something
he sounded just like Elvis and some
people thought that he was Elvis
reincarnation yeah that was like a
really good but yes possessed by the
spirit of Elvis from time to time he
actually kind of looked like Elvis a
little bit too they thought it might
have been some kind of some kin in some
way but yeah like he might have been
related I think DNA proved that he was
not related yet they were from the same
area yeah how did that ever come out I
don't know if I think they've got some
DNA off of Elvis yeah off of a hairbrush
that he had or something that's compared
and they I think that if I remember
correctly they kind of um they kind of
compared it to Orion I forgot what a
Ryan's real name was Ryan yeah
Jimmy something maybe something ruther
and he really couldn't it's hard to say
because in that part of Mississippi
we're all kind of related trail you know
you go back far enough we're all related
and it really doesn't matter what color
you are the white people are the black
people a lot of times were related well
yeah of course yeah because there was a
lot of that going and that it's just in
that area everybody's kind of related
yeah sure you know but a lot of people
came there after the war and that's what
that's what matters of whether you were
you know before the Civil War after the
Civil War you know yeah after the Civil
War is all carpetbaggers that's fake
southerners so what about what about
that story reminded you of Orion just
the dog part yeah everything just
everything about it like a spirit it's a
[ __ ] Elvis would do is it yes indeed I
guess it is
well you talkin about music and boys
don't cry and Elvis was a boy he cried
and his mama cried not that kind of
stuff you know the kids and then he his
his spirit totem was a hound dog and
that's what's all there and he would
have been a huge cure fan I think that
is probably the case [ __ ] yeah
Elvis was one of the original gods and
then Orbison took it one step further
and it Elvis said Orbison was the king
of rock and roll so the king of rock and
roll really was a guy Pro goth I like
that
I love her Harbison actually and there's
David Lynch uses that [ __ ] in his movies
like that so he he recognizes such a
this
the thing about this he was a beautiful
voice he really does have a really nice
thinking boys you guys but actually when
I'm warmed up yeah said you know he
doesn't just sing like Danzig like for a
joke and stuff like that he actually can
really sing but here's the thing about
this story that struck me I was like I'm
not sure if I'd be more creeped out if
it was like a ghost doing that [ __ ] or
if it was a person doing that [ __ ] like
there was a person like following them
like yeah Mesa I'm gonna draw arrow
while they're not looking and then I'm
gonna hide and then I'm gonna so I'm
listening to them and I'm a writer cuz
that's [ __ ] creepy too
you know what I mean because I feel like
a ghost people that [ __ ] was arrived tom
has spoken he's telling me he solved the
problem yeah yeah but I don't remember
what year that happened but seriously go
there was a spiritual evolution between
Elvis Orion and the hound dog and the
ghost of the hound dog and then the
spirit of a ride that's it's like it's
almost like an ancient Egyptian god
you're talking about yeah I like that
yeah yeah time that sounds like a jewel
instead know this existed in ancient
Egypt and Greece you didn't know that
he's like a he's like a UH like an icon
you know yeah what do you call it yeah I
guess a he's an archetype that made me
think of that song Elvis he's also
Dionysus mojo Nixon you're also Dionysus
that's right
so on that note there's also those
engineers that are prometheus that's
also Elvis Wow they used Elvis's face to
make those engineers he was a prototype
he he was pro time he said that ultimate
male so was Elvis
British version with Billy Idol that was
the British copy it was Elvis in
extraterrestrial or is oh yeah [ __ ]
right yeah he was an extraterrestrial he
was an extra testicle he was everything
he's full of beans today but anyway so
this is this was the fun Halloween intro
to the show and from now on it will be
some stuff that we recorded before like
if so if you didn't hear your story on
there obviously because I just read one
of them then it will probably get read
on the middle portion of the show unless
it was too long in which case I probably
yeah we had so many we had to like take
some out because they were just too and
this show would have been like 14 hours
I just didn't want to edit all of that
so please enjoy the remainder of the
show and like I said if you want to hear
a couple excerpts from a couple of my
fictional stories then just stay tuned
till the end I'll read them before the
little end sign out type of thing and
that will do it for this intro so I was
alright wow I forgot the lyrics the song
gonna maybe watch and watch myself on
the - how about that the search of my
friend Italy the crying crying crying
crying oh I got yeah he do [ __ ] anymore
man I'm gonna do a David Lynch reference
yeah did you just son crying I'll go
hey you guys it's the Halloween episode
what we have a guests again and also
holy crap it's been such a day we've
been drinking
we've been watching horror movies we
actually did a clown double feature
today didn't we we watched clown yeah
which I read about of my blog go check
that out and also we watched the movie
Tara fire yeah very good I I would
recommend it it was like an old-school
like slasher movie yeah we'll get cut in
half it's delightful I feel like we
should have probably watched it on a
lower-resolution television yeah this is
kind of like I said its first moral
problems you have like these
high-definition televisions yeah and you
watch these kind of like cheapest horror
movies and they look really strange yeah
but you know
oh but otherwise I would recommend it so
anyway what we were gonna do as we said
before on our Halloween special so many
of you have sent in stories whether true
or fictional or whatever so we're just
going to like read them react to them
just do our regular stuff yeah and as on
our 100th episode look we have guests
it's Shauna and Eric yeah and the
zom-baby yeah and also we got a
decapitate there's a decapitated there's
a leg yeah we have all there's all kind
of body parts go ahead so how many
stories did you actually get in from
people um lots lots of them
I don't plan that far ahead you know how
that [ __ ] goes alright I'm just gonna
like record them and see how it goes
alright so what's the first night and
also well before before we do that yeah
I have to tell you too that I was
thinking about I said well I'm gonna I'm
gonna actually read one of my own
stories on here but I couldn't decide
which one to do and then I discovered I
had written like part of like the
opening of a novel that I know
wanting to write for like the past
couple years but I haven't got around to
it I'll probably get around to it in
year or two and I was reading it back
today and I'm like hey that's pretty
good I'm probably not gonna use that but
it hasn't been published anywhere and
it's like it might be kind of neat to
read on here so at the end I'll probably
read that so if you're kind of
interested in my fiction stick around
for that because I'm gonna read this
yeah somebody actually sent us a
screenplay they did it's like here's the
thing I don't know well it's 43 pages
and it's unfinished um I'll probably
like give a rundown of it I don't know
if I'm gonna I'm gonna read it because
you know it was all kind of built up and
they haven't really got to like the
horror part yet but I have to say it was
like really good I was intrigued and I
was like uh I wonder where they're going
with this and then I was kind of like oh
it's not done so you know what I mean
may not fit within the content and yeah
and it's kind of like hard to read
because it's a screenplay so like I said
it's it's hard to read like a screenplay
and make it sound creepy or anything
like that right but some people like I
said have sent anecdotes of like stuff
that happened to them some people have
sent like fictional stories which is
fine too because I said about that so
we're just gonna kind of like I got all
the stuff here in one document and I'm
just gonna read it and then we'll see
how it goes okay so the first two are
true anecdotes
they are actually from one of our
patrons who is named Natalie I'm not
gonna use anybody's last name cuz I
didn't ask any of y'all if it was okay
so I'm just gonna use first names yeah
but you know it's like I don't like to
presume yeah I think I think Natalie
makes comments on she does yeah and
she's one of our patrons too yeah now
she sent and she also sent a photo so I
will put it in the video later on these
are just two anecdotes that she said and
these are like true things that happened
to her the first one is called White
Wolf so let us read that right now she
says I live north of Los Angeles in the
Sierra pilota mountains within the
Angeles National Angeles National Forest
north of the Sierra pallone arranged is
the infamous San Andreas Fault so we are
no strangers to earthquakes we are also
just north of the site of the Saint the
st. Francis dam
failed in 1928 and was one of the worst
civil engineering disasters in US
history
it caused massive flooding and the
deaths of at least 400 people at the
time of this story I live in a cabin
that had been built in 1929 and had been
added to but added on to over the years
so maybe a little on the ramshackle side
my mom and my son both lived with me and
we heated our home with a wood-burning
stove in other words quite rural it was
extremely dark and quiet at night and we
were far from the road
it was almost no traffic and no big
trucks passing at this time I was
volunteering every weekend with a local
wolf and wolf dog rescue as with much
rescue pack as with most rescues we had
our share of elderly and sick animals
and unfortunately deaths early morning
on July 21st I woke up because my bed
was shaking the glass started rattling
and the whole room was moving since I've
lived in California all my life out of
habit I checked the time that way you
can check the intensity of the
earthquake in the morning 4:52 a.m. it
continued for long enough that I got out
of bed and stood in the doorway before
it stopped when I got up in the morning
I asked my son and my mom if they felt
the earthquake neither one had woken up
this had happened before because they
were hard sleepers so it didn't really
bother me that I was the only one who
felt the earthquake as I was getting
ready I checked local news and the
internet for reports of the earthquake I
checked the Cal Tech website no
earthquake
no reports anywhere I felt a cold chill
this was weird I talked to my mom about
it she suggested maybe it was an
anniversary of some kind she's adjusted
checking the date of the failure of the
st. Francis dam since that was quite
close by nope that happened in March
then I thought about it it felt like an
earthquake
I looked up earthquakes on July 21st the
third largest earthquake in California
history the Bakersfield earthquake
happened at 4:52 a.m. on July 21st 1952
just north of us
it was rated as 7.5 and cause up to 4
feet of elevation to change with 12
lives lost and at least fifty million
dollars in property damage seemed a
little too exact then I saw the name of
the fault that caused it the White Wolf
fault
another cold chill as it happened one of
the wolves with whom I had formed a
close bond at the rescue had died
recently
apparently poisoned by a cane toad he
was a white arctic wolf given that I was
unable to find any logical explanation
for the earthquake I felt that night I
tend to believe that it was cloud who
was the wolf saying goodbye and she
actually sent me a picture of her and
cloud who was the little wolf that she
had fostered that had passed away at
that very time with the earthquake and
she was the only one that felt it and
apparently nobody else did so she felt
an earthquake on the anniversary of a
great earthquake it was it was the same
time as the wolf done in The Fault that
caused it was called the white wolf
fault okay and so she related it back to
like that the little white bolt they say
fostered that died at that same about
tank that's a trip that's pretty creepy
yeah I mean we have like creepy [ __ ]
happen in our house all the time so you
know yeah that's good
now the next one she said she sent
another one that was called the star of
India which is actually a ship she says
this is a hundred percent true to the
best of my recollection a few years ago
I took my mom on a special birthday trip
to San Diego you're from California you
should know all about this [ __ ] yeah
when my family first came to the United
States they lived in North Park and I
had rented a nice restored craftsman
house as a tree we decided to visit a
couple of purportedly haunted locations
in our wanderings including the Star of
India because we wanted to see if we
could sense anything when we prepared to
board the Star of India we walked up the
ramp and began to sending the storts the
short staircase to the DAC at the final
step I could feel the denseness of the
energy on the ship and pause before
setting my foot down
I felt this before they're not with this
intensity it's like layers of activity
over many years one on top of the other
I walked around the deck touching the
railings and the fixtures and feeling
the activities that had occurred on
board I could see the ship traveling
through ice fields which surprised maybe
since the ship was named star of India I
knew nothing of the history I also
sensed an accident of some kind I
invited whoever it was to tell me their
story my mother refused to go below
decks and stayed in the salon seated and
watching the people go by in touring the
ship I found out that the Star of India
had traveled between Alaska and
California for the salmon packing
industry and had traveled through ice
fields I had a deep urge to go down to
the hold where it was dark and empty but
there were too many people including the
docents who were watching to ensure
people stayed in the public areas I went
back to my mother and she explained that
some spirit had been sitting next to her
on the settee this was fine with her we
went back to the house ate dinner and
went to bed I had a vivid dream about a
friend of mine who had died a few months
previously he was working side by side
with me and our friends but we were all
cleared that he was dead I talked to him
anyway although everyone else was a
little standoffish with him he
eventually walked over to me and his
face changed it wasn't me and his
expression just became very flat and he
grabbed my upper arms looked into my
eyes and asked me if I was sure that I
wanted to do this I said yes I woke up
an intense pain because it felt like I
had been slashed on my back on each side
from my shoulders to my waist i sat up
in bed frightened and knew that the
Sailor was telling me his story the
burning pain of having both sides of my
back slashed open stayed with me for
hours when I felt able HX when I felt
able to I checked back my back in the
mirror not a mark to this day I can
still feel exactly where the slashes
were I've returned to the Star of India
sense and have communicated with the
spirit again the problem is that he does
not know what happened to him he just
knows how it felt and so do I so that
was her experience on the star of India
the ship which is purportedly haunted I
have
actually heard of that J so she must be
a psychic medium she's seeing yes like I
said this is Natalie she is one of our
patrons so hi there Natalie you were at
our Halloween - isn't that nice so how
do you feel about that Tom you are from
California yeah have you ever what have
you experienced other than Mammoth
Mountain no just math mountain basically
in a near-death experience and OBE I've
never seen any ghosts although I did end
up in a house after I was in the army
with a friend of mine Oh tell the story
in time we moved into this house it was
it was in Arlington Massachusetts
Arlington is right down there near thing
that's right off deal right up the
yellow line Orange Line no you were the
Reds red line stops at Arlington Square
no no I remember what it was been a long
time there was the old house we moved
into there and it was just weird we
moved in and no one was there they never
collected any rent from us we don't know
who owned it we were in there for about
six months and never paid any rent and
then evidently the thing got purchased
by guy and he gave us a couple weeks to
leave so it must have been being sold
for some reason but the people who owned
it never asked us free rent anyway that
was only the see to me that sounds like
the beginning of a horror movie you know
into an apartment it's like wow this is
a cool apartment whoa I got this for
super cheap and then nobody ever comes
to collect yeah nobody ever loves real
and the real earthly air is up with that
said we only had the bottom floor but we
quickly realized weeks into it that no
one was coming to check on us so we just
had free ran to the house you know we
had four floors and a basement so I
ended up living on the third floor and
it had like two rooms up in there and
she was just weird stuff I found up
I found two six crawl spaces they had
secret doors in the backs of the closets
that allowed you to go into them I have
a story about that but what was weird
about the house is Devin we were dating
girls and every time they come over they
were afraid to be by themselves in the
house and when they had to go to the
bathroom he had to walk to the bathroom
with him and what waiting for him
outside it was a creepy house yeah you
know they want to get it wait outside
why they were using them didn't want to
walk around the house by himself this is
it councils over 100 years old yeah it's
old Massachusetts House Victorians
Victorian and the layout didn't make any
sense which tell me that they changed
some of the walls you know how he had
the apartments yeah they get to the
bathroom you had to walk through
people's bedrooms and weird [ __ ] like
that that was one of the reason why I
moved up to the top floor but what got
me about that house is a feeling of
being watched kind of like mammoth
mountain but dreams bad dreams
I will woke up from a nightmare one time
I had a dream that that there was a
bunch of starving puppies in the pipes
inside the house led down into the
baseball imagine yeah I had a dream that
you know that there was that the pipes
were filled with starving puppies and I
rolled over it out of bed I was dreaming
that I've rolled over in bed I didn't
actually roll over in bed but I dreamt
that I rolled over in bed and looked
down at the ground and saw through the
floors into the pipes and down the lead
down into the basement in the bottom was
a bunch of little puppies down in there
and they were meal and trying to get out
and I did and then I woke up but it was
just a eerie Victorian three-story house
that's closest I've been to what I
thought might have been a haunted house
I had seen a poltergeist experience you
know it felt very different nothing ever
moved but everybody agreed that that was
a creepy-ass house you didn't want to be
in it by yourself you couldn't really
put your finger on it and you had bad
dreams in the house I'd walk in on Eric
you know he'd be in a room doing so I
walk in he jump sky-high like a star
what's wrong Oh
so you scared that ghosts are cheating
you just thought there's no ghosts in
here
it's like that you know that's weird
because it's like I always kind of wish
that I experience like hauntings the
only time that I've ever experienced
what you're talking about and I might
have mentioned this on another show
before one time
weirdly was in a [ __ ] Big Lots
yeah I was just like in there I was like
buying something like mundane like
Tupperware or something and I'm just
like in there in the aisle and I'm just
like oh let's buy some Tupperware about
what and then all of a sudden I had this
horrible horrible feeling like oh my
like this horrible oppressive feeling
yeah like you know how people say we're
going on yeah like when they go in
haunted house and they say oh I just
felt like super like oppressed I had to
get out of there I felt like that and
I've never felt like that before in my
whole entire life and I was what the
house and I just left I didn't buy
anything in that house I just told you I
felt that a lot yeah I had never felt
like for maybe a couple of times a week
at random times but I never saw anything
move and I never saw anything it was
just a weird feeling about the place
yeah I never really could prove it yeah
I thought maybe it was my imagination
but other people were going through a
dream right but I thought well maybe it
was just something about the way the
house looked but I couldn't figure see
anything wrong with the house it was
just big old creepy there's a lot of big
old creepy houses up in Massachusetts
tonight I grew up in one that was built
in the eighteen hundreds just a cool old
house but the first time my sister I
have experienced something we had my
sister also did too I was about 8 to
about 10 we're playing I think the Nerds
we're playing pentane from the TV you
the pimp there we play in pantomime most
friggin watching Golden Girls and
something like it made me and my sister
was like this shadowy thing and we both
looked up at each other
it wasn't even silent it just went right
in between
and went behind the TV we both looked up
at each other did you see what was that
my mother just flew in you guys are
freaking pretty easy some shadowy object
yeah you didn't look behind there wasn't
a moth or anything but yeah you know how
those some of those old Victorians were
there was a feel yeah you get a weird
yeah well they've been around for a long
time a lot of people lived in them so
there's no telling what happened in them
over the years and I don't know if maybe
your senses pick up something that
happened in the past or if there's
something actually there in the side
that's any mean it's like kind of hard
to say because the only other time other
than the weirdly random time in the Big
Lots which like I said that was the most
intense feeling that ever and it was
completely random it just came out of
nowhere the only other time I've had
that feeling I was in my grandmother's
house which I lived in growing up like a
lot and never anything creepy nothing at
all now my grandfather died he didn't
die in the house he died in nursing home
he was cremated and his ashes were in
the house they were in like a um you
know like a china cabinet that was in
the dining room and for some reason like
one day I was like sitting in the dining
room like working on some [ __ ] like on
the day at the dining room table like I
did and then all of a sudden I felt very
very strongly that someone was standing
behind me and that's where the ashes
worried they were right behind me in the
china cabinet and I had never felt that
before like but I really really felt
like someone was back there like so
intensely that I thought like maybe it
was my sister and one of my brothers or
something like that so I was like what
the [ __ ] and like no one was there and
that doesn't happen to me very much I
mean everybody that watches the show I'm
like super skeptical and stuff so that
doesn't happen and so that time and the
time in Big Lots that's the only times
that's ever happened to me and I grew up
in a house in South Daytona it's not
there anymore it's been torn down
it was my other grandmother's my
maternal grandfather's house and my mom
and all her sisters and brothers grew up
there and they all said that they either
saw go so they heard footsteps on the
ceiling
or whatever or they had seen things
where the house was haunted and I lived
there for probably a couple years off
and on and I never saw her at anything
it's a creepy house but I never saw her
at anything so you know the fact that
that was supposedly a haunted house and
I never saw her hurt or anything it was
a cool house I still put in a lot of my
stories and stuff like that but I never
saw heard anything there but I did see
and hear some stuff in like other random
locations so you know that should tell
you something right there
but now since we're talking about bad
dreams let's kind of go off on a tangent
what is the worst dream you've ever had
if any of you can remember can you
remember what the worst dream you ever
had was this is a Halloween show
find some creep [ __ ] but I was like what
was it oh but you remember I was sick
and I would have these friggin of
horrifying fever dreams that I was in
hell and time moved like kind of
backwards and I had to like work my way
backwards through time to get out of
hell yeah it would happen like recurring
when I was probably just like my brain
frying up like my head probably 6 in
real life I went to my granddad's house
in San Diego all right and he had on a
mantle a ship in a bottle
you know memberships in the bottle and I
pulled that little bottle down and they
showed to me had a little ship in there
and I was
at that ship and I was thinking for how
small would you have to be to be inside
that [ __ ] that really happened in real
life later on I was asleep and I had
this dream that there was something
attached to my face and tried to pull it
off and I turn it I had a huge spider
wrapper on my face like that he hates
and as and I saw like the camera pan
back where I was and I was inside that
little ship in that bottle with a big
spider about five that was and I
remember that dream to this day and that
was the scariest dream I'd ever had yeah
that's five spider wrapped around my
face and a camera pan back I was tiny
inside that ship and oh my god five or
six No
my mom had to snap me out of that she
ran in the room woke me up woke me up
and that's that's what one of the few
nightmares I remembered over the years
yeah that might have been to hurt my
first nightmare it's pretty bad you know
it's funny the one I remember from when
I was a kid um if you grew up in Florida
you went to Disney World when you were a
kid which I did quite often the snow
white ride I haven't been on in many
years so I don't really remember what
it's really like but I had a nightmare
about it when I was little that like I
was kind of in I don't remember if I was
so much in a ride but it was kind of
like I was walking through this kind of
big room and it was like super dark and
black and stuff and then like coming up
out of the floor were these like fake
alligators you know what I mean like I
think there's like a fake alligator in
the snow white rider in the not the snow
white right but the [ __ ] the Peter
Pan ride that has the alligators coming
up out of the floor and so they were
like these fake alligators like coming
up out of the floor and it was like
freaking me out like I'm like walking
through them like oh my god she's
[ __ ] alligators because I'm scared of
alligators in real life so they're like
these fake alligators but I was like
super scared of them but in my dream for
some reason I saved myself by pulling
this little let me
how can I describe this it was like a
little patch of hair it was like about
this like as big as like a big band-aid
and it was like a magic carpet and I put
it down and I stood on it and that I
could fly yes so then I kind of then I
flew over the alligators and I'm like no
that's probably seven when I had this
one I used to love to go out my backyard
and take a little little shovels and dig
trenches into the ground put and then
turn the hose on and fill everything
with water you know drama make canyons
and make waterfalls and make ponds and
[ __ ] you know I mean in my backyard I my
daddy get furious cuz that terrible
you're killing all my clothes yeah had a
garden hose
well I had a dream I was doing that it's
making a river filling that [ __ ] up full
of water I'm having fun I'm playing with
toys and I look up and here comes a
[ __ ] pirate ship down river that I
made is about four feet long like a toy
wouldn't pirate ship about four feet
long come look at that bad [ __ ]
yeah there's somebody on the deck now
look it's a little bit of you sandy
[Laughter]
sandy shooting a [ __ ] flintlock yeah
six shooters right sarvesh down grab his
ass grab his ass like that off the deck
and bit into lucky his gods though be
news hit him broke open into that cherry
pie filling from McDonald's it burned my
[ __ ] mouth it was like that was that
was a dream this is the one you're
kidding anyway the cherry pie McDonald's
the shitbird
well I did that to you Sammy Sam it
wasn't blood it was pie filling and bit
him like that oh it burns he told me
that we were we were like at walkie one
day he told me about that you're I'm
like
that is the most awesome dream I've ever
heard of you picked up a tiny Yosemite
Sam and bit into him and he had cherry
pie filling I mean it was amazing that's
a mystery part but we'll see it made
sense at the time it made sense all
dreams make sense at this thing is I see
the [ __ ] pirate ship coming it's only
four feet long so I thought I was
Godzilla
so I attacked that [ __ ] like Godzilla
would tak this yeah I gotta grab me a
semi sim trying to bite his head off but
I didn't bite his head off I bit into
that hat you know a pirate hat and fit
through that pirate hat the pirate hat
and yeah that's what had to pay it but
it was his head - it's all he was Hollow
Jerry private caution it's hot feeling
as hot yeah now that you're talking now
that you're talking about it I just
remembered another really horrible dream
I had this was the dream and this
actually wasn't that long ago because I
remember waking up and you were awake
and you psyche why are you [ __ ]
kicking me hmm I will tell you why I was
kicking you and I actually read a short
story based on this - because I didn't
Jack yeah I do that sometimes
so I had a dream that me and him were
living in it seemed almost kind of like
it was like an apartment building more
like a college dorm there was like other
people around and we were like in this
room and I dreamed that I woke up in the
middle of the night and that I heard
someone's TV it's like playing like in
another room and I got up and I'm like
walking down the hall and then I see
this person like a guy and he's in this
room and he has a TV and he's like
yelling at the woman on the TV she's
like a newscaster or something like that
and he's like yelling it's like you
can't you [ __ ] judge ah he's like
that and I'm like okay [ __ ] that [ __ ]
and I was like that's really weird and
creepy and so then I go downstairs and
it's like super dark and I go in the
kitchen and it's really dark and I start
like making a sandwich or something like
that and then like this girl comes down
from downstairs
and I'm like there's like siren
like some noise like coming from outside
I'm like I wonder what's going on down
there and she's like totally being weird
like whatever and she's like in the
shadows and I can't really see her and
I'm just like okay whatever that chicks
a total [ __ ] so I'm just going about my
business and then all of a sudden like I
decide oh okay I'm gonna wash the knife
that I used to like make the sandwich or
whatever so I'm at the sink and I'm like
washing the knife and then this the door
opens and there's like a like a frat
house or something like that like across
the street which and that's another
thing like I said my grandfather's house
in South Daytona that I grew up in was
across the street from a frat house and
actually now it's been torn down and
they built a frat house for embry-riddle
university on the site of the house so
now there's two frat houses so it's two
times the time it's yeah so it's two
times as terrifying so yeah so there's a
frat house and there's like a party
going on over there but it's like far
away there's like lights and noise and
stuff so I'm like looking out over there
and there's lights and I'm like I wonder
what's going on over there so then I'm
like just washing the knife or whatever
meant the sink it's all dark and then
all of a sudden like the door opens and
then this couple comes in it's like this
guy and this girl and they're like
making out like as they're coming in the
door like and they're like you know what
I mean and I'm just like okay I'm just
gonna present him right here or whatever
I'm just like not a part of this so then
they're like making out and stuff and
then it starts to get like super weird
like he kind of like pushes her down on
the floor and then he grabs her ankles
and then like pulls her legs apart like
really and I'm like oh my and in my
dreaming mind I thought to myself he's
gonna pull her feet off which I know
he's not rational but I thought he's
gonna pull her feet off the way he was
and and then he did he did he was like
he was like that and he was like yeah
and he just like pulled her feet off
yeah and then I was like I'm just like
standing there like it to sink like
washing the knife like [ __ ] what do I do
like I was like I wanted to run and like
I couldn't and then like he whips around
and he looks at me and I can remember
what he looked like he had like this big
face like this big forehead he had blond
hair was
all swept-back he'd like these ice blue
eyes like ice I super remember what like
if I saw him in person I would recognize
him yeah I'm like I'm like looking at
like oh [ __ ] and like then he's like
starts coming at me and I'm like oh [ __ ]
and like I have the knife and he grabbed
my wrist and I took the knife that was
it was just like a butter knife or
something I was just like that cuz I
didn't know what else to do and he's
just like yeah whatever and then I
started kicking at him but because there
was a bar like in between you know that
I was just like kicking [ __ ] whatever
like the you know the material that was
in between and then at that stage like I
woke up and I was kicking him and then
he woke up and he's like why are you
kicking me and I'm like cause you were
gonna stab me uhm then I'm like it's
like I was dreaming yeah I was like
trying to like I was trying to kick him
like gently yeah it was like and I that
was like that was like one of the worst
dreams I ever had and I actually I
actually turned that into a short story
which maybe I should rape on this show
I'll try to find it later it's in it's
in my [ __ ] computer somewhere but yeah
I turned that into a shorts right
because that's risky my good dreams get
the [ __ ] out of that was it yeah it's
like this nowadays whenever I have a
dream I'm always about 22 I'm dreaming
I'm you know my own age I'm always like
much yogurt and I'm always like either
22 or min high school no not with you
guys
I have reoccurring dreams where I'm back
in high school and I damn can't figure
out what class I have next I'm looking
at my school schedule
[Laughter]
your subconscious can just dream up
alternate personalities and they'll
fight you really weird yeah they're
parts of you they happy I mean you would
think yeah that's what I yeah and like
that has occurred to me that's why I
wrote a story about it cuz I was trying
to like work through my feelings because
I don't usually you know and people
would think that because I write horror
and I read all this horrible [ __ ] I read
about your crime I read horror stories
you would think that I have a lot of
nightmares but I really don't I have had
a few that I remember but really not
that many it's like I don't really
remember a lot of my dreams most and
they're very boring
the couple of nightmares that I've had
I've written stories about them and then
you know that was kind of the end and
actually a few stories a few nightmares
that I've had
I was actually the perpetrator I was
actually the killer I actually had a
dream that I was the ghost face killer
from scream at one point like not too
long after that maybe came out I dreamed
I was like walking down the streets like
near near where my grandmother lived in
Daytona Holly Hill area and I dreamed
that I was the ghost face killer I don't
actually dream that I'm usually me I
usually dream that I'm other characters
and I will move to different characters
as the story progresses I guess because
I'm a writer and I guess because I watch
a lot of movies so yeah I just feel like
and the perspective changes like
sometimes they'll be like oh sometimes
I'll be me but sometimes I'll be this
other person and sometimes yeah
I'm always me yeah no not me
I'm not usually me in my dreams it's
it's I don't know it's it's hard to
explain most of time I get in trouble in
my dreams I got guns with me and as I
start using them to get weaker weaker
and smaller and smaller
[Laughter]
kandi caters us like goddamn to them and
then it runs out of water
they just throw it at people I had one
dream where I was beating a [ __ ]
assassin knocked him out and jumped on
top and started stomping on him and I
looked there was nothing that but a
greasy spot so you dig this down reisi
spot I don't remember any the crushing
is just where'd you go I was building
shoes there you be the man clothes and
shoes I have to tell you though that's
like you seemingly I mean you used to
have much worst nightmares then you do
now because now you seem like you just
you fall asleep and you to sleep back
like many years ago yeah
you used to be like you would talk in
your sleep you would you're like flail
around like [ __ ] bah bah bah
you'd be like flailing around here sleep
a lot like that you know what I mean
being attacked by dogs fighting piano
all constant you don't yeah so I don't
you know yeah I don't know if it's just
like because you're older now you've
kind of gone yeah one of the ones that I
would never remember it
sometimes yeah cuz I'd wake you'll be
like what the [ __ ] you just smack me in
the face with yeah there was one of
those kind of reoccurring you know over
a period of many decades was that I
thought I was underneath the pile of a
bunch of dogs that were just tear me
apart fighting yeah yeah and then as
soon as I wake up I don't know I forget
it like go back to sleep I was worried
about that because you know I by about
2000 sometimes I would wake up at like
2:00 or 3:00 in the morning and I'd hear
you going and [ __ ] yeah they even like
look like fresh rhino this is like when
I was you know
like ex girlfriends and wives and
ex-wives and stuff they were just like
never wake me up I'd be making growling
noises because I was making the noises
of the dogs there okay so does anybody
else have dreams of their teeth falling
out or just me yeah and they they hit
the ground like hit the desk and a bunch
is like like a bunch of corn you cut
about the corn cob is booming they hit
and the teeth see all connected the
weird thing it's like your teeth falling
up like Figaro is like I didn't know but
I hear that's a very common dream theme
like I've had a lot of them and it's
usually it usually occurs in a dream
that that is not even related to teeth
in any way at all like one time I
dreamed something like totally Monday
and like it was in the [ __ ]
McDonald's drive-through RIS and [ __ ]
and then like I'm ordering my Egg
McMuffin or whatever and then all of a
sudden I feel my teeth line it's always
super super realistic like they're
realistic that when I wake up I'm like
[ __ ] yeah
my teeth are gone and then I'm like a
bowl there yeah they say I feel them
like going over my lips I feel them like
falling out of my mouth so it's like
when I wake up I'm always like super
weirded out because like oh my god I
don't have any teeth now it has
something to do with feelings of
powerlessness it that's what I've heard
and I've heard something yeah I've heard
that it might be like super like a
throwback because it's like losing your
teeth I mean in nature means that you're
gonna starve to death I mean in the
natural world
maybe yeah cuz I might do that too I
think I've done that too I think I grind
my teeth in my sleep too so that might
be that might be some of it but yeah
that's like a recurring and I have that
happen like all the time and another
thing that happens too and maybe you
guys know something about this also
whatever I'm sleeping and I have to pee
and my body's trying to wake me up I
always always always have a dream that
I'm looking for a bathroom but every
bathroom I find is super disgusting
it's either super disgusting or there's
like a murderer in there there's always
some reason I can't use it like I'm
always like yeah it's like I'm always
like oh I have to pee and it's like and
then I go in this bathroom and then it's
like it looks like like I said like the
bathrooms in Trainspotting
or there's like or there's like a serial
killer that it was like lurking the next
stall or something so there's always
still like some reason I can't use it so
I feel like that's like my brain boom
like hey dummy wake up because you have
to pee don't wait the bag you know what
I mean so I think that's very funny as
like yeah so maybe like other it's like
I have that I have that a lot because
you know what I mean because sometimes
we sleep before you go to bed and it's
like you know it's like I'll have to pee
like at 3:00 or 4:00 in the morning and
then I'll start dreaming that I'm like
whatever I was dreaming and then I'm
like oh we need to find a bathroom I say
to my dream friend and then it's like
did I go in there and it's like this
[ __ ] horror movie bathroom and I'm
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] then I wake why but
you know like she's always having dreams
about somebody coming for I never really
have that it's always animals or
monsters I've been attacked by
Frankenstein's Frankenstein's monsters
zombies
okay never remember we were kid there's
an old video game called berserk
I remember that already had to fight
these robots mm-hmm and one of the
robots was a bouncing head with a smiley
face on her angry face on it I got
chased by one of those just a bouncing
ball with a face on it dad I'm scared me
that's kind of disturbing again it was
in his bouncing like a slow motion
oh don't collect something my man had a
face on it I remember the most
terrifying dream I had in Jenny I know
I'm gonna turn this into a story that's
good no I was I was in high school I
think and I don't
deep-water undiscovered and just lying
your dis mouse underneath
weird like kind of pop and there were
these huge like tanks but they were
these for whatever reason they were made
out of cement and they were they were
for keeping like shocks that dwell like
just ridiculous of water but they would
be like these trench type pools and I
remember I woke myself up from what it
was so terrifying because there was a
there was one [ __ ] just deep like
Marianas friggin trench style deepness
[Music]
yeah it's like I've had dreams where I
was like just in this really deep water
and then all of a sudden I see this big
I like right here like but you know
remember the old ride they had at Disney
that's where I got that yeah from what
was it 20,000 Leagues sse right yeah I
used to love that ride but it scared the
[ __ ] out of me yeah yeah it's like when
you're little though it's like it's
submarine it only went like what 2 feet
you could see the surface if it was like
that yeah I above the submarine version
when you were a little kid like you
really felt like you were underwater and
feel like you're in the submarine and
all of a sudden is a big [ __ ] squid I
like comes across and that like really
traumatized me a lot when I was little
so I had a lot of nightmares about being
in this big huge ocean and then all of a
sudden this big huge mass comes back all
those rides at Disneyland look like [ __ ]
well they do that all the paint's just
looks like faded rubber or you don't
know that none of the and none of the
creatures look real it says you know
what though it kind of makes me sad
though that you can't that people can't
like approach things the way they
approach them when they were children
because it seems like I mean [ __ ] scares
you a lot more when you were a kid they
don't keep that I kind of Miss that I
used to not like I want to be
traumatized every day because that would
probably suck but it's like I you know
it's like I don't see a lot of movies
anymore like look when I was at
did I saw [ __ ] what was the movie
with the rabbits [ __ ] watership down
and it [ __ ] traumatized me I saw my
Bloody Valentine which I probably should
have been watching it the age I was at
when it came out but you know I saw it
and it [ __ ] it kept me up for like
two nights I was like oh my god a dude
with the pickaxe is gonna come out of my
closet and like [ __ ] get you know I
mean and it's like I kind of missed that
feeling as traumatic as it was
you kind of want that real is like this
[ __ ] really happy yeah and it's you know
I mean we kind of talked about this a
little bit I think we talked about it a
little bit on our we were talking about
a house with a clock in its walls
because I was like so happy that when we
saw cuz that's my favorite book when I
was a kid cuz I thought it was really
scary and I was like I thought it was
cool that when they made it into a movie
now finally even though the book came
out like in the early 70s they actually
made it pretty scary I mean for a little
kid boy if a little kid saw it they'd
probably think it was really scary and I
thought that was pretty cool because
when I was a kid [ __ ] was really scary
but also it was kind of awesome and I
would go back and see it again even
though it scared the [ __ ] and I kind of
feel like there's not a lot of that
nowadays you know what I mean
that's what I mean it's like everyone's
so jaded now and it's like that's that's
pretty lame that's pretty now the next
one is actually a fiction story good so
I'm gonna read this this is bye
and I hope I'm pronouncing your write
your name right I'm just gonna say your
first name I'm not saying the last name
like I said this is a story by and uh
and the story is called the index finger
alright so I'm gonna read this never
probably take a little bit of it alright
the room was gloomy and dim the only
light came from the flashing images on
the television and it created shadows
along the peeling walls on the screen
the face of a man appeared he's older
than he likes to think he is she thought
and she was right it was obvious that
some lady behind the cameras did her
best with makeup to cover up the circles
under his eyes and the dark spots on his
forehead that he probably got years ago
from alcohol consumption she wondered
how come they didn't add a much younger
woman next to the poor fossil she took a
chip out of the bowl in her lap most of
them were soggy because she had opened
the bag yesterday but this one gave up a
satisfying crunch the man on TV reminded
her of someone but she couldn't put her
finger on it someone she met years ago
he had the same lightless eyes they
frightened her and she knew she had
experienced this feeling before someone
else had looked at her like that another
chimp no crunch it was years ago 10
maybe 20 she was much younger then than
she was now she certainly didn't have
grey hairs back then she started getting
those late in her 40s but that feeling
came way before her 40s she remembered
eyes like that used to follow her a lot
when she was younger she liked that she
missed that no crunch the man wasn't on
the TV anymore
they cut to some fat lady crying about a
murder that took place in her
neighborhood she thought about the fact
that she was about 20 pounds heavier
than she should have been maybe that's
why men didn't look at her the way they
used to no crunch the man was back now
she saw those dangerous eyes the type of
eyes that were able not only to scan
through your clothes men liked doing
that but he could see through your skin
through your flesh and inside your soul
like he knew who you were and he
despised you for being so typical no
crunch she started thinking back on her
youth when fat women on TV didn't remind
her of herself
it was one of the men who liked looking
at her that had those eyes it must have
been one of them one of them gave her
that look which one
surely she couldn't remember every man
that ever looked at her with unorthodox
thoughts but she knew she could remember
the one who looked at her that way no
crunch she was working as a waitress
back then he must have been one of her
clients right and it was cold outside
he must have been her right he must it
uh god damn it it must have been winter
because she remembered a pain in her
buttocks and she always tripped on ice
in the beginning of the winter she
learned to be a lot more careful with
time no crunch yes it was winter she had
to mop the floor after every hour she
remembered him vaguely he sat at the
table furthest from the door in the same
corner teenager couples liked to sit so
they could snog without being disturbed
he wasn't particularly good-looking but
he was an ugly either he had a very
common face maybe that's why she
couldn't remember him properly no crunch
she took his order without really
looking at him and when she brought him
the food he gave her that look she
didn't remember provoking him she used
to be very polite with clients maybe she
could have said something while being
pissed off because of the bruise she had
in her butt however seeing his eyes she
mumbled an apology even if she hadn't
done anything wrong no crunch those eyes
even now years later she could remember
his eyes perfectly like the Polaroid of
his eyes was burned under the surface of
her brain something crawled on her spine
the same eyes were looking at her now
from the TV no crunch that was the
problem the balding man on TV was
looking at her no crunch no he couldn't
really look at her no crunch he was
looking into the camera no crunch people
can't see you through the TV that's
silly
no crunch but he could he watched her he
saw her and he hated her no crunch
why is she wondered why did the man on
TV hate her why did the man in the
dinner in the diner hate her all those
years ago
crunch she hadn't done anything to them
she was always nice and she tried to be
friendly to everyone
crunch-crunch-crunch
she couldn't give attention to every man
who desired it though there were a lot
of men that wanted to be noticed but she
couldn't bother with all of them which
woman can and about the ones that were
older or married surely she couldn't
bother with those it would have been
wrong to give attention to those men
crunch and what about the ones that she
just didn't like what about the men that
were just were common and the ones that
drank excessively and started losing
their hair no woman should bother with
those she felt something warm in her
mouth she looked down at the bowl there
were no more chips but the bowl wasn't
empty she looked at her right hand and
counted the fingers there were five just
like there's always been one of them had
a red river running from it though and
it was shorter her right index finger
was missing its first knuckle where was
it was the only thought she could form
the metallic taste in her mouth
overwhelmed her she put up her red hand
and spit oh there it is the end yeah I
like that's very very much all right so
our listener Gianna and I hope I'm
pronouncing that right but she sent us a
couple of experiences that she had very
experiences so where can I gonna relate
those she has actually titled them the
first one is called the vortex of anger
and the second one is called screaming
in the night so I'm gonna read those
right now okay this is your vortex of
anger yeah she says these two
experiences happen to us in the
apartment we currently live in taking
place soon after we move in back in 2004
and lasted for a little more than two
years the first experience we noticed
soon after moving in during June of 2004
with it being the summer we open on the
windows in the bedroom and living room
open these windows facing out the front
of the apartment building which is a six
unit converted mansion in Buffalo's
historic Allentown neighborhood our
apartment is on the third floor and is
the top floor we live on Arlington place
right next to Arlington Place which is
surrounded by houses or old mansions
like ours we're one block from
Street where there's a huge bar scene
where many famous Buffalo bars can be
found like the old pink Mulligan's brick
bar and me cheese many late-night
revelers often cut through the park
using a diagonal path from College
Street to Arlington place on their way
to North Street and more residential
blocks with the windows open those
summer months it didn't take long for
Scott and I that's her boyfriend
yeah to notice something that seemed to
happen with some regularity often you'd
hear people fighting out on the sidewalk
in front of our building heated
arguments shouting or sometimes outright
physical struggling and fist fighting
the freaky thing that we started to
notice about this was that oftentimes it
involved people that were obviously
friends who then turned on each other
when they stepped in front of our
building you'd hear a group of people
cutting through the park together after
a night of drinking they'd be laughing
having a great time joking and carrying
on and then they'd get to the sidewalk
out in front of our house and band
they'd start shouting or outright
physically fighting we started to joke
and call the area out front of our house
the vortex of anger because there was
something swirling around out there that
caused people to lose their [ __ ] but it
started to get really freaky when one
hot summer week three separate times
twice on consecutive nights we heard
people who appeared to be friends one
moment get into huge brawls right in
front of our place and next with one
particular group
I remember hearing one of the guys
grabbing the other like c'mere you [ __ ]
and the girl in the party shouting leave
him alone another of those three
incidents that week two guys broke out
in a physical fight and I can hear one
of them shouting at the other [ __ ] you
repeatedly for some distance as they
chased the other it was at this point I
turned to Scott in bed and said this is
really beginning to freak me out
domestic shouting matches between
couples random arguments unexplained
screams and say of single people it was
constant one time Scott said that he was
sitting out on the stoop out front
drinking his coffee and reading the news
on his phone when a homeless man came
along and as soon as he stepped in front
of the house he threw down his
belongings started stomping his feet and
shouting [ __ ] at the top of his
lungs he wasn't shouting at Scott just
shouting in general Scott described it
as a sudden chemical or electrical
change where he just sprang into this
transform feral person another time when
Scott's sister Nancy and her husband
Ford came to visit us they too broke out
into a heat
argument as soon as they stepped in
front of our place there were too many
incidents to count I would say on
average we noticed in about two or three
times per week and there were times who
noticed that more than once per day the
other experience that I don't know if
it's related but it should be noted that
the head of our bed at the time was
located just under our bedroom windows
that face in front of the house happened
maybe a year later now in retrospect and
let's be honest as soon as the next
morning this event was pretty hilarious
but at the time it was happening to me
and unfortunately to Scott it was
terrifying this experience happened
twice the same way months apart I
apparently had a nightmare which I do
not recall and did not recall as the
event was happening as I slept I moved
toward Scott in bed grabbed him by the
collar and pulled his face right up to
my own and started shouting repeatedly
oh my god oh my god oh my god what I
woke to was the site of his startled
face his eyes flying open so I think my
eyes had to be open even though I was
asleep and that's what woke me finally
to the sheer state of terror and I'm me
and terror I was coiled up real tight
and had this impending feeling akin to
there being an ax murderer in the house
and he was about to kill us in her bed I
then broke out in hysterical bawling
Scott of course got up put on the lights
got me something to drink calm me down
etc the second time it happened months
later as I was waking up still shouting
I knew I had done it before exactly the
same way what's weird is that the second
time I felt a bad presence in the room
with us it could very well have been my
overactive imagination but for some
reason I shut my eyes and wouldn't look
around particularly the foot of the bed
towards the entrance to our bedroom both
times afterwards I seemed to go back to
sleep with little incident and didn't
really dwell on it which in retrospect
was odd
again it's funny as hell to think about
poor Scott being startled awake by his
mad wife screaming like a loon in his
face he's a very nice guy we laugh about
it a lot and thankfully it hasn't
repeated we noticed that things quieted
down after a couple of years with the
vortex and realized this kind of
coincided with us getting our dog Machon
she's a half border collie half lab mix
in a very sweet dog not aggressive at
all but is very protective of us and
often sleeps just outside our bedroom
door facing outward our lives down at
the top
the stairs looking downward the
staircase to the third floor starts
within the door of our apartment so the
stairs are part of our unit but it's
probably a normal dog behavior if this
is our first dog so we really don't know
also we since moved our bed against
another wall so it's no longer located
just under the windows and it should be
noted Scott a filmmaker who directed a
film on Laura Secord in the war of 1812
had a little tidbit to share with me
that I can share here he told me that a
long North Street which is around the
corner from us and in the direction
where most of the revelers head to a
huge battle in the war of 1812 took
place it was the Battle of December 29
30 29th and 30th of 1813 that burning a
buffalo with hundreds of scalp soldiers
littering the road which at the time is
called guide board road the retreating
American soldiers were ambushed by the
Native American allies of the British
don't know if it's related but it's
there to ponder attached you'll find a
photo of the front of the house which I
will put in the video and a pic of mooch
on our protector which I also put in the
video because she didn't send me that
just and she says happy Halloween which
will also be their 23rd anniversary
their happy anniversary
this reminds you of another case there
was a case that happened in the 90s and
it was one of the first times I ever saw
some video evidence that was presented
on TV and it was one remember there was
an old 90s TV series I think was called
sightings I think it was sightings it
was off a pair of psychology department
got called into this house and they set
up video cameras in there and they
captured some pretty weird video footage
I found it on YouTube it's still out
there I don't know if I can find it
again what it happened was a couple
moved into the house I think they bought
the house they were only in there for a
few months sitting they were still
setting the place up it wasn't even
fully furnished wasn't even fully
decorated yet they were like a happily
married couple they hadn't been married
that long but for some reason they kept
fighting each other and the fights got
worse and worse they were over nothing
one night they were in the kitchen and
they started fighting
and it's the fight started to escalate
and them I think it was the woman looked
over the man's shoulder and saw behind
him a big red ball oh they did that's on
the haunting or paranoid right they did
yeah and of course she pointed she goes
look and he saw it and it kind of
dissipated and sometime later I think
might been a few days later they were
fighting again and that red ball came at
that guy
when he saw and it kind of vaguely
looked like a man
and it he could I think he said that it
kind of cocked back like it was gonna
punch him and it did hit him but it
didn't really hit him in the way that a
fist would hit you it hit him in almost
like a spiritual way and they fled the
house well they went to some University
and that had a pair of psychology
department and they told them what had
happened and they said cameras up in the
house and they got some pretty weird
footage one of them was just tearing the
day you could see a shadow moving along
the wall like there was somebody walking
down the hallway but there wasn't
anybody there and when it got to the end
of the hallway it went it was like that
shadow disappeared into the living room
and then the door shut and it was nobody
in there and then and then I got another
shot of a box they had a camera up and a
up and a near the ceiling up in a corner
he's probably up on a little tripod a
box of books fell over because they have
bad men's stuff there when they ran like
a packing box of books fell over and the
books just came out like something
scattered him and there was like it
looked like a lawn chairs
then you know I'm in and it flipped over
there's nobody there you can't see it
it's like the books yeah yeah I'm gonna
try to find it maybe we'll put it in a
video and then the third thing that I
remember from that is they had a camera
in the kitchen and you see the cupboard
start - oh I break and the silverware
drawer pulls out silverware just starts
flying up and you could see that things
were shaking the camera started to shake
and then it just buzzed out into static
yeah and that was all they said it was
pretty weird when I saw it it reminded
me of math Mountain and I was like
that's kind of like the stuff that would
happen now I don't know what happened
that pair of psychology group I don't
know what happened to that case I
remember what it was called but the
video on it looked Connor Connor uh you
know impressive yeah kind of convincing
but I haven't seen it in a long time I
need to look go back and look at it
again but I remember that I remember
getting kind of chills seeing the video
going yeah it's kind of what I saw I do
remember them doing a reenactment of
that on it was either a haunting or
paranormal witness I can't yeah or one
of those like paranormal shows yeah
destination America or something like
that
she'll like that happens in our house
though I'll see if I can try it yeah
that that was the stuff that happens
here those a lot more mild now it is
yeah but like I said we kind of
mentioned this on some stuff yes missed
that it turns the TV on actually turn
the TV on all the times on TV oh no I
come out here like every third morning
in the [ __ ] TV is and do the remote
it also stole a couple of my what are
you trying to like
[Laughter]
knocking on the back of this wall no I
got that music it also stole a couple of
my things yeah and stole a couple of
your things yeah we're still missing the
lighter well we're still missing a bunch
of things I'm missing a ring I'm missing
a like a little pajamas like a night
dress and I'm you know we're missing the
grill later yeah
also they go lighter that long yeah I
don't know where the hell that went kind
of you really and I we always like the
first thing we jump to is like oh well
the cat took it but where would she take
it it's like if she took it she would
put it under the bed because that's
where she puts everything I wonder what
she's trying to prove I have a necklace
that's like it's like a pendant but then
like it's not a chain it's like a ribbon
and for some reason she really really
wants to eat that so like every time I
like leave it out like on the counter or
something
she will pick it up in her mouth and
just like and it'll just go down her
throat and I'm just like pulling it like
gross like can you not like this is like
in your stomach and I have to like pull
it out and then act like dry it out and
stuff because it's like all has like
[ __ ] kidding it's so gross but it's
like I have to hide it from her because
she will totally eat it if I leave it
out she seriously our kid needs
everything so I said what's that second
case alright so this one this is from
Sabine now her and her husband are the
same woman right no this is okay okay
all right yes that person was too right
yeah but they were kind of related okay
yeah this one is this is a totally
different thing all right
this room Sabine her and her husband are
big fans so she wanted to kind of relate
this so she burned it out some [ __ ] to
happen so she says I once worked as an
usher in an old cinema in the West End
of London called the Prince Charles
cinema this was back in the early 2000s
despite the grand name it was more like
a grand house theater that showed
second-run movies and held midnight
screenings the Rocky Horror Picture Show
it was actually a former porno cinema
back in the 70s and before that was a
theatrical haul that dated back to the
1800s so this is quite an old place and
there was talk amongst his staff that it
was haunted
I could totally believe this because the
building definitely had an atmosphere
one of the chores for us
uh sure was to wrap a chain around the
rear doors at the end of the night and
we all hated doing this because it
involved walking down a long narrow
corridor that was inaccessible to the
public this corridor seemed to stretch
on for miles and you always felt like
someone or something was watching you as
you walk down it we would run to the end
of the corridor through the chain on as
quick as we could and then scramble back
to the main auditorium now full
disclosure whilst the building
definitely had an atmosphere and I felt
there could be some kind of presence
there I never actually witnessed
anything you'd call paranormal however a
number of my co-workers did hear a
couple of spooky incidents I remember
the head projectionists was a very
down-to-earth woman who was very
mechanically minded and was the least
likely person to believe in anything
supernatural but she had had a bunch of
weird experiences and soon became
convinced that there was some kind of
entity haunting the cinema one of her
jobs would be to clean the lamps that
lined the walls of the main auditorium
she would do this in the morning before
the cinema opened one morning she was
cleaning the lamps using her usual
method of standing on a stepladder and
wiping each lamp with a dust cloth which
he would toss with for when she was
finished when she got to the final lamp
she wiped it with the dust cloth tossed
it to the floor climbed down from the
stepladder and then turned around only
to find that all of the cloth she
discarded were scattered around the
utters horn were draped over the seats
as if someone had thrown them around
with great force there was no one else
in the cinema at the time stepping up a
gear there was another projection as to
worked part-time at the cinema he was
based in Cheshire which is 160 miles
from London obviously too far to commute
from so to save on hotel bills he would
sleep in the projection booth in a
sleeping bag
again he was a solid down-to-earth guy
but even he began to get creeped out
when it's sleeping alone in the building
he would hear strange noises in the
middle of the night sometimes the phone
in the projection booth which was a
direct line would ring and he would
answer it only to hear silence on the
other end that always creeps me out I'm
sorry even in movies that creeps me out
at first he put this down to a prank
pulled by one of the staff but we also
were blind that we had nothing to do
with it gradually he started to feel
more uncomfortable about sleeping there
then one night things came to a head
when he was woken by the sound of
banging coming from below in the
auditorium he switched on the lights and
looked out through the window of the
projection booth but there was no one in
sight being a pretty big imposing guy he
wasn't afraid to confront whoever had
broken into the cinema so he went down
into the auditorium and called out
whoever was hiding there to show
themselves before he called the police
there was no answer
he called out again and this time heard
a loud bang coming from the middle of
the stalls
he walked further down the aisle but saw
no one annoyed and on edge he turned to
walk back to the projection booth and
then froze standing in the window of the
room was a dark figure staring down to
him totally freaked out he rushed up the
stairs to the booth only to find it
empty
just to note there was only one narrow
staircase that linked the booth with the
auditorium so no one could have got past
him to our collective disbelief he
continued to sleep in the projection
booth even after this various other
weird incidents continued to happen but
eventually I got another job that paid a
touch more than minimum wage so I quit
my job as an usher moved on occasionally
I go back to the PCC as a patron and
although the staff have changed and the
building has been refurbished I wouldn't
be surprised if similar things have
happened have continued to happen to
this day so I feel like theaters are
like super haunted like I feel like
there's a lot of that stuff I think we
even saw a couple like I said I'm
paranormal mr. Dold
particularly in the UK I feel like
there's like you're at a high
probably that one and you know people
working in them sometime in the past a
long time you know that was that that
was kind of like the center of the
community like the theater that was the
main medium of entertainment so back in
those days I can see that that that
phone ringing and nobody was there on
the other end that's and always wears me
out yeah yeah
even like him but here's the thing it's
like it's weird because in movies like a
lot of [ __ ] that is made like jump
scares and so like that doesn't really
scare me
[ __ ] that scares me is like little [ __ ]
okay
yeah like [ __ ] like oh the phones ring
and there's nobody there or like David
Lynch [ __ ] where it's like hey I'm right
here but really I'm is also like you
know people being in two places what
that like freaks me the [ __ ] out I don't
know why but this yeah it's just like a
little subtle [ __ ] like that that freaks
me out I have people talking in
different voices that creeps me out also
I had some kind of like what happened oh
oh I know so yeah I know this right this
is good yeah I came back and I was in
the third grade not came back from
school and I got home before my parents
got home so I was by myself for a couple
of hours for the showed up and on this
particular day though actually I had
stayed home from school that's what it
was and I was watching The Twilight Zone
and as I loved The Twilight Zone I was a
kid and I was sitting there in front of
the television watching The Twilight
Zone and I heard the telephone rang and
it rang so wild that it startled me I
jumped up to run to the phone and as I
was running to the phone I was like why
to stop ringing did I miss it
well I picked it up and as I picked up
the receiver I heard two people talking
to each other on the phone I'm called
hello hello and they're not answering me
and I'm just listening to what they're
saying and I'm thinking that's my aunt
Ruthie and I said that's my aunt Ruthie
talking and I hear her having a
conversation with somebody
yeah and when hello hello and then it
just kind of faded away and I'm standing
there with a damn telephone and I don't
remember any kind of dial tone or
anything so I put it down and I was like
why is weird guy had butterflies in my
stomach you know you know you had that
butterfly feeling like what was that all
about
so I sit down from the television to
continue to watch Twilight Zone all
things you know probably about 30
minutes later a car pulled up in the in
the in the driveway and I looked at it
was a white pickup truck
no it wasn't a white pickup truck
there's a white it was just a white
little car I think some reason I thought
it was a pickup truck but that might
have been my dad had a pickup truck at
that time anyway I look I see who gets
out and it was my aunt Ruthy I hadn't
seen her in months and with her was her
husband and I had met him he's my my
uncle they just got married they were
young he's people are in their 20s they
said where's your mom and dad said
they're at work I said you know I'm home
from school it's okay we're gonna go to
spires and get something to eat
once you come with us we'll watch it
until they come home I'm like all right
so I get in the back of the car that's
why I'm saying it wasn't a truck or
somebody's knows things with Cobra I was
in the backseat and they're driving
maybe it was a truck but I think it was
a car I'm driving and I said I said I
said I heard you on the telephone and I
was like 6 7 and he said you heard of
someone's helping me this yeah heard you
guys talking on telephone and they're
like yeah whatever they kept talking and
then they're talking to everybody and
they had the same conversation that I
had heard on the telephone okay that's
creepy I said I heard you guys talk
about that on telephone it was just like
you know about things about tickets
plane tickets that's what it was like
mundane Jay Monday [ __ ] I heard you guys
saying that on telephone and they're
like yeah
and it is just some kind of weird
premonition that I had I don't think the
telephone rang see stuff like that is
like creepy I don't think it writing I
think I think I foresaw their arrival
and I think I foresaw the arrival and
the the conversation but in order to
receive the message somehow I think my
subconscious made me go to the telephone
to get to get the to get the message now
here's the weird thing about some of
these weird psychic phenomenon I don't
think it's supernatural I think animals
do it and there's some evidence the
animals that's what I think kids are
good at it yeah evidently an animal can
tell they've proven we do tell it
through through cameras that an animal
can tell when their masters coming back
home when there should be no way for
that animal to know that they can't hear
that car they're not in the same car the
right car they're not on a pattern they
just know they go to the window they're
like oh mommy's coming home and go on to
explore to face great somehow they
somehow ever see it it's something
something instinctive it's not some high
brain function it's a low brain function
I think it's something that animals do
and somehow as we mature and develop we
learn not to do that because maybe it's
good maybe when you're home you know
like I've been laying affect your life
in a way of it but I think it's instinct
of some sort yeah yeah and it may have
some do with quantum entanglement cuz
here's the phase you're around people
you become entangled with them on a
quantum level and it's kind of like
spooky action at a distance it's almost
kind of like radio frequencies but you
can just feel it well there's a that
you're close to right exactly exactly
because I could call my mom when I was a
little kid just by wine or beer with my
friends after spending the night scared
what of all cuz you had that madman like
you thought that your aunt Ruthie called
you and even though she maybe didn't
call you it wasn't like import
no we know or anything she was just
coming yeah it was just like a mundane
kind of thing it's like they were just
having a mundane conversation so that
kind of makes me think that maybe
psychic powers exist but it's not
anything it it doesn't have like any
rhyme or reason like it's not anything
like oh there's this big thing like
someone's dying and you have to like
it's just like mundane mother [ __ ]
lighting actions
randomly I think it's when it comes to
little kids
it's the same thing that happens with
certain animals animals going to the
door knowing that the Masters coming
home soon and they have it on camera
this is there's no way this dog can know
that this guy's coming he's not in the
right car and he's coming home earlier
and how could that dog know they had
some they did a study on that's weird
your dog or you can't knows when you're
coming home that's weird so it's there's
some entanglement somewhere the Stuart
Hameroff is probably gonna say well it's
quantum has some do want with
consciousness because you know that
person you kind of know where they're
common you know that they're common for
you just like when the animals can sense
death hurricane and hurricane yeah
exactly and it might be many factors
kind of like a precognition also may be
like being able to pick up on vibrations
happenin and pressure and weird things
all kind of coming in together but you
know it's just I don't think it's
supernatural I think it's nacho I think
it's natural I always like tease baby
cookie because sometimes she will come
in my office and she'll jump up on my
desk and then she will do this weird
thing where she like sits on the desk
and that she like suddenly stares off
into the distance and I'm just like I'm
like are you looking you're looking at
ghosts right you can tell me it's cool
but of course she's not gonna tell me
she's a cat she can't talk but like I do
feel like she's probably looking at
something because she does that all the
time like sometimes she'll like being
the should we run around the bedroom
just doing her [ __ ] and then like all of
a seneschal stop and then she'll like
and look up in the corner like what's
that up there I'm like oh my god there's
a [ __ ] demon up there
animals its koi it's probably a boss
animals definitely imagine because
they'll they do I think I think she
doesn't mind with it
she doesn't something else they can
definitely imagine and I think they
sometimes think and imagine they're
looking off in the distance probably
imagined into something that they want
or something like I think it's a lot of
it I would really love if they could do
you know kind of more in depth like look
into like animals like minds are their
thought processes because I mean baby
cookie the way like I watch her like the
way she interacts and stuff like that
and I'm like wondering is she seeing
stuff that's like actually happening or
she's like remembering stuff because
like one of her favorite things there's
this little lizard no seriously there's
this little lizard with no tail and he
lives like outside of our bathroom
window and she loves a [ __ ] lizard so
she keeps like looking she's like I was
a lizard there today oh he is and then
she'll jump up on the thing and then
like try to get him even though he's
outside and so like I'm always kind of
wondering is she just like remembering
that that about that lizard being there
or is she like looking at something that
I can't know she knows so it kind of
creeps me out should that she does but
you know she's you know all right so the
next story this is actually just like a
little funny anecdote and actually I
kind of relate to this because I have
some [ __ ] that's similar this the story
was sent to us by a fella named a Victor
he says this isn't a scary story but
it's kind of creepy kind of cool and
100% true when I went up to college at
UTSA in San Antonio I got paired up with
my roommate who is from Austin one night
we were bored and up late and he told me
the story about this road called
Southwest Parkway out in the hills
around Austin in the middle of Southwest
Parkway were the words
long live wolf spray painted in huge
white letters supposedly it was a
tribute to a kid named wolf who was hit
and hit and killed by a car while
walking on the side of the road it
became a tradition that when you drive
over
those words you're supposed to lift your
feet up off the floor board like some
places have that like when you go over a
bridge or an overpass like that so
gantry yeah being young and bored with
nothing better to do we decided to drive
all the way to Austin in the middle of
the night just so I could see for myself
we finally made it to Southwest Parkway
and as we're coming up to where the
words were spray-painted in the middle
of the street the radio station we were
listening to went all static I hit scan
and just as I saw the words la live wolf
illuminated by my headlights the radio
station started playing hungry like the
wolf like oh my god my phone does that
[ __ ] all the time
we lifted our feet as we drove over and
both looked at each other like holy [ __ ]
is this really happening maybe it was
just crazy coincidence maybe it was
something supernatural but to this day
almost 20 years later we still talk
about that night I have to tell you my
phone which is a little Samsung Android
when I used to commute back and forth to
work every time the weather was shitty
on my way home from work my phone would
play every single song I had that had
rain in the title I don't know how it
knew it just did it would play clan of
xym acts like whatever that rain song is
called it would play [ __ ] tones on
tail rain it would play yeah play every
song I had on my phone that had rain in
the title just all in a row I don't know
how it knew how to do that but it's in
so that used to creep me out like I
remember like driving home in the shitty
weather and be like really how like how
do you know this is bothering ya my
phone used to do that so I kind of
wonder how how does my phone know what
[ __ ] songs to play and I also used to
play here's another thing used to do it
used to always play
I had a few songs that had like [ __ ]
the title like Nazi Punk's [ __ ] off you
know whatever [ __ ] you by Lily Allen it
had like some other songs that had
[ __ ] the title and it would play all
those in boxes and it would also play
all the songs that were in the German
language in a row also I'm not sure why
I would do this it might have something
to do some algorithms together something
but four summaries like I'd be driving
how that I'm like where all the [ __ ]
songs playing together that's pretty
weird
aren't you tell them about the fire
boss Tori what my sorry you saw the damn
UFO okay now this was a long time ago
this was actually probably before me and
you even got together right I think I
knew you at that sage but I was still
living in Daytona I used to work the
night shift at a newspaper
remember those I used to work in video
tuna beach news journal when I lived in
Daytona and I worked from 5:30 to 2:30
a.m. 5:30 p.m. to 2:30 a.m. so I was
always driving home in the middle of the
[ __ ] night there was no one around it
wasn't like a big like traffic area I
kind of lived in a residential area so
I'm driving home one night
actually I had driven home for dinner
and then I was driving back so it was
only like maybe 11 12 o'clock so I'm
driving back to the newspaper and I see
in the sky a big giant fireball and I'm
not even saying like I'm not
exaggerating it wasn't like some little
it wasn't like some little it was a
shooting star no it was a big fireball
if you had it in your hand holding it
out in the arm but this is how big would
it be it was like this bit it was like
this big like an orange like 1/10 I got
an orange yeah so if you were holding it
out if you like orange or tennis ball
yeah okay it was that big was like a
fireball the first thing I thought well
okay I had just read fill plates book
death from the skies where he was
talking about it's like in a he's an
astronomer so he was like talking about
all the all the horrible [ __ ] that could
happen to you like felt was like oh look
it's like gamma rays and also that kind
of stuff but from a scientific
standpoint but it was still kind of
funny so I had just read that like
literally a week before so the first
thing I thought was oh [ __ ] this is the
extinction level event we're like that
was literally the first thing I thought
because I'm like a science nerd and I
was just kind of like well this is how
we go like the dinosaurs a nice nice
going humans this is the end of it so I
thought it was that and then after that
I was sitting there going maybe it's a
plane made like maybe explain exploded
or maybe you know maybe a shuttle took
off and on it know about it maybe it
exploded because it described exactly
what you're seeing it's it was a
fireball was it coming straight at you
it seemed like yeah it was very big and
it was like it was just up in the sky
like I'm just driving and it was
like coming at this like at me like that
and it was very low like I said like
orange or like you know tennis
ball-sized so like I said first thing I
thought was asteroid and I'm like well
we're [ __ ] and I was like ball that
sucks and I'm going back to work you
know um probably about 30 seconds 30
seconds it was a long time because I'm
like driving and I'm like holy [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] like we're dead um I don't remember
lighting up the ground but it was yeah
it was just like really weird and then
like this is a long time it is it was a
long time the second I got back to work
I'm like you guys are guys guys it's
like I saw this huge thing I'm like okay
we're not dead yet so obviously it
wasn't a big huge [ __ ] dinosaur
killing asteroid I'm like so did a plane
explode or something like that did you
guys hear anything and they're like we
didn't hear anything so I look on the
internet I'm like was there like some
kind of playing explosion or a rocket
explosion or something and it's like I
looked and there was nothing there was
nothing the moon like seriously how
[ __ ] dumb do you think I don't know
driving you couldn't you were driving
could you really focus on it yeah
because it was in front of me in front
it wasn't like I was like looking in my
mirror hi Rison was it like at that's
the horizon how high was it about thirty
five degrees like that yes and it seemed
to be coming straight it was right in
front of me and it was it was it's just
solid or was it boiling or we talked
about it was like an explosion like it
was like a fireball explosion weird
enough that like I said I know what the
goddamn moon looks like um it wasn't
that like I know they always say like
the UFO oh it's Jupiter if it's a like I
know what a [ __ ] plane it looks like
I know what the moon looks like it
wasn't like that it looked like an
explosion it was the first thing I
thought like I said first thing I
thought was it was a huge asteroid and
oh my god were [ __ ] the second thing I
thought was it was a plane that exploded
that's what it looked like it looked
like a plane or a rocket that exploded
in the sky that's what it looked like
what happened anyway because look I
remember very clearly when
the space shuttle Columbia exploded you
know we all saw it you know we we were
in school and we went out to watch it
it's like I was in the cafeteria but I
saw it on TV like right after it
happened so it's like I remember what
that looks like it looked like that but
more fiery and bigger so the so I
thought that it was like something that
I didn't think it was like a UFO or
anything went away I don't actually
remember what happened because I was
like freaking out like the first thing I
thought was like oh my god that's an
asteroid and we're all gonna die in like
10 seconds yeah because I just read that
book like I said but then when I got
back to work I was kind of like hey did
you guys hear about an asteroid was it
in there like it was too unclear but you
didn't really see it vanish then you
looked away when you look back no it
didn't vanish it was just kind of like
there and then I was like driving back
to work and then I couldn't see it
anymore like I don't really remember
like you know what I mean all right he
doesn't buy it no no I know I think you
saw so much don't know the woods how can
I be any clearer I don't know it was a
big explosion in the sky and it wasn't
the moon imagine seeing a big huge
asteroid like the first thing I felt
like I said I thought it was a big huge
asteroid like you know okay you're like
I know right yeah there is no chance it
could have been a reflection no no way
no there's no way it's like here's the
thing like okay you know when you used
to watch the Discovery Channel what it
was good when they actually had
educational programs instead of [ __ ]
no you don't remember that no okay well
back in the old days when they had like
documentaries about you know like the
Cretaceous you know the event that like
told other dinosaurs and sometimes they
would have like the computer animation
like oh here's the the planet-killer
that came and killed all the dinosaurs
it looked like that it looked like that
that's why the first thing I thought
because I like I said I just read that
book I'm Leslie [ __ ] I do too and like
that was the weird thing like I got back
to work on places like it was an
asteroid and like I looked online no one
reported it
no one saw any there was no plane
explosion nothing
could have been a meteor falling star
coming right it could have been but it
was very large
that's it I'm hoping it was just that
but it was very very large probably
coming straight in it was large enough
to like alarm me and it you didn't look
like it was moving it was just getting
bigger well I mean I interpreted that
sure thing is is a falling star isn't up
there for 30 seconds that's that happens
it might have been 30 seconds but it was
a long time it was a long time I just
remember driving I was from my house I
was on Derbyshire Road and I was just
passing that what used to be a 7-eleven
and then it was like now it's sold like
some yes York yeah and I was like sure I
was like what the [ __ ] is that and I was
like I thought I'm like oh [ __ ] okay
what else we have all right so here is
the next story is by a girl named
Brianna all right
let's sing that Fleetwood Mac song yeah
obligatory yes so she says so this story
probably isn't as scary as some of the
other ones people have submitted but
it's still a cool story and happened to
me I'm a skeptic when it comes to
anything paranormal
same here I've been on ghost haunted
some pretty well-known locations but
never experienced anything convincing I
just split with my ex-husband and moved
into an upstairs apartment in a really
old house I have a cat named saga my
friend Amy was over helping me unpack
and organize things we were in my
bedroom I was over by the bed and she
was standing in the bedroom doorway I
was looking right at her we were talking
and suddenly she says oh hey saga and
bends over to pet my cat who wasn't
there she looked over at me confused and
said what the [ __ ] I just felt a cat rub
on my legs we both just thought it was
weird and kept doing what we were doing
a couple weeks later when I was all
settled in my friend Brian and his
teenage daughter Sarah stopped over to
see my place we were sitting in my
living room talking and Sarah was on the
living-room floor playing with saga she
looked up at me and asked what my other
cat's name was I told her I don't have
another cat and she said she saw black
cats and
at the end of the hallway when they
walked in ya ghost cats in the house
that happened sometimes the apartment
was laid out so that when you walked in
there was a long hallway first thing the
hallway had doorways on both sides one
went into the living room went into the
kitchen at the end of the hallway was
the door to my bedroom
Sara said she saw a black cat sitting
right in my bedroom door when she walked
in the same place Amy felt a cat rub her
legs about a month later in my friend
Eric and his roommate Christine sat by
Christine didn't know me that well at
the time and while petting saga she
casually asked me so you just have the
two cats I told her I only have one cat
she said you guessed it that she had
seen a black cat sitting in the doorway
to my bedroom when they first walked in
I never saw the cat but several people
saw it while I lived in that apartment
they all described it as a large black
long-haired cat sitting in my bedroom
doorway it was always people who didn't
know the story he brought it up to so it
wasn't just people claiming to see it
after I had put the idea in their heads
was weird I had a cat named Vlad who
died shortly before my axis flit up he
fit the description of the cat everyone
was seeing I'm a skeptic through and
through but I still wonder if his ghost
stayed with me and followed me to my new
place now I live in a house and there
have been no black cat sightings there
yet I kind of hoped that I would
actually rather like cats be ghosts than
humans like I don't think I would be all
that upset like if I if I had a kitty
that died and then it showed up again me
yeah but if it's like if it was a human
I'd be like oh [ __ ] what are you still
doing here
you know what I mean
yeah no talent like I said I hope go sir
ghosts are always you know just it's an
unknown I had a near-death experience on
motorcycle wreck I felt like I went
somewhere you know who knows what an
animal can do or what happens to them
you know I don't know what happens to
them when they die maybe the same thing
that happens to us but what do they do
they merge with some kind of cosmic
consciousness do they evolve up into a
higher you know spiritual form and then
you know reincarnate into like you're
going up through progression you know
think they do probably see it's like in
India you know I don't know there's no
telling you won't know until we get
there I feel like it's more likely for
animals to do that because they probably
don't though will they probably like
well they're humans they're maybe their
whole world especially if they're not a
difference between a human and an animal
there's really not that it's just a
varying degrees it's all the same kind
of DNA just to code it out a little bit
differently I mean if if a human has kin
if a human consciousness can somehow
survive death with like Stuart Hameroff
s--
concept of with what they would call
quantum soul theory which just you can
look up Stuart Hameroff and he can
explain it better than me he's he's you
know he's deep into it he's an
anesthesiologist and he's hanging out
with Roger Penrose his uh you know his
this is a cyst and you know they're
trying to study what consciousness what
consciousness is in the brain well if
the human consciousness can perceive
reality in certain forms of reality
after the brain is gone the human can do
that what's to say that a cat could I
really think there isn't anything that
says a cat couldn't if a human can do it
then a cat could probably do it too it
just depends on what a cat would do
once it loses its body would probably go
off and do weird [ __ ] to play in the
Freeman's like I said they evolve up
kind of like in the Indian model you
know I mean or maybe you just
reincarnate as into whatever you want to
be like I'm gonna be eagle next time or
I'm gonna be a you know
yeah I'm gonna be a human now I would be
an elephant or maybe I'm being an alien
on another planet there's no there's no
talent you know I can't feel like maybe
maybe if the animals were super into
their humans they might like maybe hang
around it's infinite possibilities you
just we won't really know until we get
there we're looking at baby cookies you
ready yeah oh she's coming over here
right now
are you gonna jump up in the chair all
right what else you got all right so
this story is by someone named Chris we
had all these stories I know yeah I told
you I - it down the story's alright this
is funny this is a person named Chris
also known as journey planet he says my
dad was a paranormal fan dating back to
late 1960s he was friends with Sylvia
Browne and various other Santa Clara
County researchers he was supposed to go
to the famous Toys R Us investigation oh
my god we talked about that like haunted
Toys R Us on yeah in the late 1970s yeah
yeah there was a documentary about it
except had to watch me while my mom
worked the story he told me about why he
got so interested in ghosts was amazing
and probably the scariest image I've
ever thought of my dad was something
like seven or eight years old and
visiting his grandmother in Watsonville
California she lived in an old late pict
Orion era house that was facing a large
field of artichokes the house had a huge
front porch that the boys often played
under grandma used to tell stories about
they and forgive me if I'm pronouncing
this wrong the mutton Aloni our tribe
that had lived on the land centuries
before colonization it was late and dad
had crawled out of the bed and went
outside to play with the dogs and was
standing on the porch when he could
smell smoke like it was a huge burning
fire just down the way Dan walked down
to the bottom of the steps and he could
see a lot of men on horses in the
distance carrying torches he said there
were about 20 or 30 of them he was
looking at them for a while and then
on top to the side and saw about 50
people standing all looked like his
grandma mixed heritage Aloni wearing old
Mexican clothes like they were from the
late 19th century dad wasn't scared to
suddenly see them at all in fact he felt
extremely calmed but when he looked back
at the men on horses he felt deep terror
as if they had already stripped
everything from him and we're coming
back for his soul dad was frozen in
place but he called over to the Ohlone
saying who are they no one responded and
when he finally looked closely at their
faces he noticed that the eyes were
blank not black but not white either at
that moment he saw the men on horses
start trotting towards the house and he
was so scared he jumped off the bottom
step to dive under the porch but the
moment his feet touched the ground he
felt a flush of searing fire pass over
him and then he actually dove under the
porch and he saw a massive wall of fire
sweep across the artichoke field
everywhere he looked was burning and it
wasn't just the field but several small
low structures that hadn't been there
before
he heard screams and could see men and
women running some of them on fire and
then the men on horseback came and
chased them dad buried his head under
his arms and bawled himself up and after
our moment the heat was gone and it was
cold and freezing which was weird for
summer in California he pulled his arms
off his head and looked out the entire
field was burned but there was no smoke
and no one was moving he saw a few
bodies of people and as he stepped out
from under the porch he could hear a
wailing cry a woman screaming cry it was
terrifying so he ran into the house and
spent the entire rest of the night
looking out the window across the field
which was back to what it had been from
before everything he had seen the night
before except for crows hundreds and
hundreds of crows that had settled on
the field dad told me the story a couple
of times with the last time he finished
with icehole grandma the next morning
and she said I don't even have to set
foot on the soil anymore to see the fire
Johnny I can see it from up here every
night
so he saw like a fire that happened in
the past yeah
and he kept seeing it like stories like
this are not really stories of a bunch
of ghosts coming back you know what I
mean haunting an area I think it's too
unlikely but I think that is does
someone seeing that something that
happened in the past talking about
or maybe one ghost sends you a message
and that message is a vision of
something to happen in the back
Californian okay you're from there yeah
it's just not any of us
I was thinking about the Indians a lot
of you guys don't know this how much I'm
gonna tell you something though when I
was in the first the five or six up in
Korea for a little while my squad leader
was a guy named sergeant's Lamar oh I
forgot what his first name was I think
he's in my year bucket look at but his
father was Lonnie Zamora the guy who
reported the UFO out there remember the
policeman to saw the UFO yeah yeah
desert that was my my squad leaders dad
and I had first heard about that when I
was in the army I'd never heard of
Lonnie Zamora the cop this that saw some
kind of a spacecraft landing guys get
out a minute left and the FBI and yeah I
think it was the FBI came and questioned
him about it said he saw a symbol on it
I heard that I heard two sergeants
amaura and another one of the NCOs they
were sitting up on their cots we were on
the DMZ the guard post Collier and they
were talking about he's your dad someone
to saw that UFO and they were talking
about it and I was overhearing him and I
didn't realize it that he was offender
that was a famous UFO case that was the
first time I had heard about it but what
was funny is that he was under the
impression that his dad
didn't think it was an alien craft that
he thought was an experimental craft
when we saw that movie the other day
member first man mm-hmm remember how
Armstrong's flying around that trainer
for the lunar lander he's flying it
around yeah that's similar kinda to what
lines amaura saw so it was egg-shaped
but that was just a little a little
bonus material for you people guys who
like UFOs will do you Rendlesham yes one
of these days I know like a lot of
people on tomorrow the song was my squad
leader oh I was like yeah we could do a
whole show about that yeah and like I
said I think you've told this during
this year before about your the plane
that you saw that didn't look yeah we
bring that up a lot words I gotta have
people's memories are [ __ ] up too
plain stories the the plane that I saw
that I couldn't figure out what it was
and then the time I was on the DMZ and I
saw light a plane fly across the DMZ and
I reported it and everything and I don't
know if I fell asleep and hallucinate
and dad or if I actually saw that no
planes should have been crossed the DMZ
and I said I just saw a plane across the
DMZ and no you didn't say yeah I did
headlights on it I was bronzy and they
said well which was gonna have fast and
everything and they logged it wasn't I
was in that bunker with another guy he
was asleep and I said no I mean I didn't
wake him up
I saw it though and I don't know if I
was just it was awful cold that night
you know maybe I hallucinate it I don't
know I I believe I saw it
like I said people's brain they're gone
it's kind of scary you think about but
like your brain is not as reliable as
you
this is some I think that scares me more
than anything else that I'm just gonna
like start seeing [ __ ] that isn't there
I'm gonna start thinking [ __ ] that
doesn't happen it's like you know what I
mean it's creepy that's why I think so
so many people are disturbed by like you
know getting like dementia and stuff
like that because it's like that's gotta
be really scary man all right
hey just like I said at the beginning of
the show at the end I wanted to do a
little bonus segment with me just
reading a couple of you know little
fragments of some stories that I wrote
so we'll get on with that the first one
is actually from my compilation called
hopeful monsters which is available on
Amazon and print and ebook format
eventually it will also be available in
audiobook format it's actually been out
for a while it came out 2009 I'm going
to release it probably next year
sometime it's like a new cover and
things like that and with an audiobook
also but it is available in print an
eBook format so I'm just gonna read a
little bit of a story from there and
then as I mentioned on the earlier
segment that had Sean and Eric on it I
actually found part of a novel that I've
been working on that you know I've kind
of been playing with for the last couple
years and I you know just wanted to read
like a little bit if I don't know if I'm
actually gonna use this particular
fragment or not but it was it was
something that I kind of liked and I had
forgotten about writing so I'm gonna put
that on here as well so without further
delay I'm going to read you just the
first couple little sections of my story
which is called
Rara Avis the sky was just starting to
darken as Pamela Runyon left the store a
bag in each hand
she had parked as close as the crowded
lot had allowed since the accident which
her mind always insisted on in closing
in quotes she hadn't felt much like
walking far the lights around the
parking lot were beginning to flicker to
life as she stowed her bags in the trunk
she dropped her keys swore and stooped
to pick them up she heard a car pull
into the space next to hers but she
didn't pay much attention an owl who did
somewhere in the tree is nearby
Pamela straightened up keys in hand but
then she was grabbed from behind she
opened her mouth to scream but a hand
clamped over it and she just had time to
think what long fingers the hand had
before she felt a sharp blow to the back
of her head after that nothing it was
dark but she could see a little from a
faint green glow to her left
an alien light she moved her head and
groaned at the pain there was a rush of
noise in her ears a feeling
movement there were figures very close
hulking in the shadows just at the edges
of her vision at least two figures maybe
more Pamela had the impression of large
yellow eyes of something like fur of
strange protrusions above the heads that
could have been horns confused and
unsettled by this disjointed but vivid
nightmare she rolled over and pulled her
sweater around herself wondering where
her husband was had he got up to go to
the bathroom thinking he would be back
soon she closed her eyes again and was
soon unconscious when Pamela came fully
awake some unknown span of time later
the first thing she was aware of was
darkness and the clothes pungent smell
of hay after a few moments she also
began to focus on sounds there were
furtive small rustlings in the corners
which might have been bugs or mice and
there were louder more deliberate sounds
which were definitely made by something
much larger these other noises seemed to
be coming from somewhere below her her
head throbbing pamela tried to move but
found that her wrists and ankles were
bound was something that felt like thick
rope she tugged at her bonds but they
had been expertly knotted and held tight
trying to keep quiet in case someone was
nearby she struggled hard for a few
minutes thrashing her arms and legs
trying to loosen the ropes it was
hopeless panting she settled back
against the misshapen mattress she was
lying on she then realized that she was
naked but covered with a scratchy thin
blanket that smelled musky like a horse
her heart was beating hard in her chest
but otherwise she felt oddly calm
detached she twisted her head wincing at
the pain which seemed less acute than
before but still raw above her she could
just make out the faint outline of what
might have been a high curtain'd window
with moonlight filtering unevenly around
the edges she wondered almost idly if
anyone outside would hear her if she
screamed before she could find out
Pamela heard a heavy rhythmic creaking
like the sound of footsteps on a wooden
staircase as the creaking grew louder
she also thought she could hear a
regular but muffled rasping breath in
and out like the wheeze of an asthmatic
once she had realized the implications
of these sounds her strange calm
suddenly ramped up into pulse-pounding
terror and panic and she began to
struggle again
violently this time her limbs contorting
and inhuman spasms and her desperate
attempts to get free she grunted and
swore and screamed thrashing against the
lumpy mattress the blanket was thrown
off her body and she felt the nip of a
cool night breeze on her skin which
pushed her to struggle harder let me go
she said into the darkness which was now
laden with an obvious presence she
wanted her words to sound fierce and
fearless and authoritative instead they
came out as a pitiful squeak she could
see the figure now dimly as it seemed to
emerge slowly from the floor
her friends heed mine took a few long
seconds to determine that it was
actually climbing up into the room from
below either from a staircase or a
ladder another few seconds elapsed
before she put all the clues together
and deduced that she was being held
captive in the loft of a barn the sparse
moonlight from above
illuminated only a vague silhouette but
as the figure drew close
Pamela could plainly see that this was
not a normal person if indeed it was a
person at all its dimensions were
roughly human-like and it appeared to
walk on two legs and to have a roundish
head but there the similarity stopped
there was a flash of large golden eyes
and horns or antennae protruding from
the crown of the creature it's shoulders
were fairly narrow like a person's but
they flared oddly out and down giving it
the appearance of armless Ness Pamela
tried to curl her trust and vulnerable
body as far away from the approaching
thing as the ropes would allow please
she said not knowing where to look on
the creature and finally focusing on the
yellow glints that might have been its
eyes please don't hurt me I won't won't
what she realized she'd been trying to
think of something some bargain she
could make in exchange for her freedom
but what could she give this creature
what did it want from her I won't tell
anyone about you she said which seemed
meaningless but it was all she could
think of the creature didn't answer it
was very close to the edge of the
mattress now and his Pamela watched in
horror it leaned down toward her she
wanted to turn her face away not see
what this thing looked like and she
whimpered and cried but in the end she
kept looking couldn't tear her eyes away
from it its face was oddly flat and
covered with something soft upon closer
inspection this
hovering proof to be feathers which were
mostly white but turned to a darker
Brown around the edges there were indeed
huge round disks for eyes glowing yellow
in the dimness the pupils fixed and
black and staring a tiny pearly beak
jutted from where the nose would be on a
human being
pamela wanted to scream but the sound
died in her throat
the creature was looking at her but its
eyes did not move its expression did not
change in a swift motion it reached down
and picked up the blanket from the floor
and placed it back over her with what
she could see now were perfectly normal
human arms which had previously been
concealed under a long poncho I'm sorry
about this the creature whispered it was
a woman's voice pamela realized with a
start although she couldn't determine
from where the voice had issued since
the creatures face had not moved why
have you brought me here
pamela asked her heart finally resuming
a normal beat she felt much better now
that she was covered up again and now
that she knew this thing could talk
could feel sympathy the bird woman
didn't answer right away instead she sat
down on the floor crossing her legs her
face now on a level with Pamela's I
brought you something to eat she said
I'm sorry about the ropes but I can't
undo them Pamela tried to force herself
into a sitting position but only
succeeded in straining her limbs
painfully she gave up what do you want
from me I don't have anything to give
you she suddenly remembered waking up
earlier in the van or whatever it had
been there had been others at least two
more besides this one there are more of
you aren't there yes down below the
creature produced a bowl from somewhere
under the poncho and started its
contents with a wooden spoon you have to
eat now keep up your strength strength
for what in the dimness Pamela could see
the spoon coming toward her laden with
some kind of colorless mush she was
hungry but she had to admit it didn't
look very appetizing
what is it justice to eat it the
creature pushed the spoon at Pamela's
mouth and Pamela grudgingly took a bite
the stuff was gritty and fibrous and
tasted slightly of maple not good but
not as horrible as she was expecting
after a few more bites she looked up
into the creatures stony face you're not
planning to kill me are you
it seemed a silly question why would
they be feeding
her and trying to keep her warm if they
were intending to kill her but then why
else would they want a kidnapper the
bird woman looked down into the bowl
stirring it the mush absently no her
voice was still muffled as though she
was speaking through a mouthful of sand
she looked up at Pamela again finish
your food
Pamela opened her mouth to receive the
spoon and neither of them spoke again
when the bowl of mush was empty the
creature got to its feet and with the
last glance down at the prisoner turned
and made its way back down the ladder
Pamela lay back against the mattress
shivering despite the blanket she'd
wanted to think that this was all some
hideously realistic dream but the cold
on her skin and the thick vaguely
unpleasant taste of maple on her tongue
were too potent to be a figment of her
sleeping mind okay
so that was that as I said that story is
called Brera Avis and it's in my book
hopeful monsters and after I take this
short little editing break I will read
you a little bit of a sort of a novel
I've been working on for the last couple
years which like I said I'll probably
won't get around to writing it for
another several years but I just thought
I'd read you guys a few paragraphs from
it and see what you guys thought so I
will be back in just a second
okay and here is the second unpublished
fragment of a novel that I've been
working front on for the past couple
years so you know let me know what you
guys think in the comments you know
you're not going to talk me out of this
Brigid lifted her coffee mug to her lips
and drank her eyes above the rim were
smiling but wary Kade smirked at his
wife across the breakfast table I'm not
trying to I just want you to have all
the relevant information before you make
the final decision and is it relevant
this information Kade shrugged you know
how it goes could be important could be
nothing
Brigid tapped her fingers on the
tabletop she was a study in contrast her
sharp small face said against an untamed
thicket of dark hair that nearly
engulfed it her expression at once
sternly annoyed and softly receptive so
tell me she said well it was a dream he
said and before her expected I role had
even reached its apex he qualified I
know how you feel about that but this
one seemed significant symbolic like I
said I don't know what it means if it
even means anything she considered him
silently for a long moment then shook
her head with a laugh I don't mean to be
an [ __ ] I do trust your judgment she
said you're in this too she reached
across the table and took his hand so
what was this dream Cade was standing in
the dimmed hallway of a hospital ward
listening to the sound of his own
heartbeat on either side stretched walls
of plexiglass seemingly endless meeting
at some point far off on the horizon he
began walking and his footfalls made no
sound on the dull white tiles a metal
frame door drew his attention to the
left and compulsion dictated that he
opened the door and walked through
inside on the other side of the
plexiglass wall were arrayed rows of
identical gray cradles Cade peered into
the nearest of these and saw a tiny
infant wizened and unmoving but staring
up at him with pale eyes that held an
unsettling intelligence as he moved
along the rows he saw that each cradle
contained a similar child
none of the babies squirmed or cried
though all were clearly alive and
watching him a faint burning aroma
plucked at his nostrils
suddenly Kaede noticed a man standing
over one of the cradles gazing down at
the child within the man was small
standing no more than four feet his
limbs were bluish white and bone could
be seen prominently beneath the papery
flesh the expression on his face was one
of despair but there was also a kindness
there a tenderness toward the object of
his attention another mistake
the man whispered and raised his head to
meet Kaede scrutiny a crushing sadness
overtook Kaede then and the burning
smell grew more pronounced as Kaede
watched the man reached into the breast
pocket of his work shirt and produced a
rose fashioned of red glass about the
size of a half dollar it was exquisitely
formed it's overlapping petals tinged on
their edges with sprinkles of ground
glass that glinted like miniature
diamonds gingerly the man placed the
rose on the baby's sunken stomach the
moment the man removed his hand the
infant shattered like a ceramic tea cup
cracks radiating forth from the Roses
deep scarlet center Kaede recoiled in
horror but the man did not seem to react
his expression bore the same resigned
sorrow as before he stepped back then
into the shadows and faded away like a
phantom Kaede approached the cradle not
wanting to look down at the broken
pieces of the infant in the cradle but
unable to stop himself the shards began
to pulse and vibrate on the gray counter
pain and then tendrils began to sprout
forth curling up toward the ceiling and
thickening into Roby vines the vines
knotted together and shot up and started
to branch out word and before Kaede
could blink he was standing in a forest
clearing with late afternoon sunlight
slanting down upon the layer of dead
leaves beneath his feet the tree that
had grown from the child's cradle was
now affixed strong oak and Kate
approached it uncertainly his hand
reaching out of his own accord to stroke
the rough bark as he did this he became
aware of a strange sound a sort of
click-click click-click coming from
somewhere above him he peered up into
the branches but saw nothing all of a
sudden his fingers encountered a gash in
the trees trunk as if something carved
there and he pulled his hand back to
look he was sure there had been
break-in the tree surface before but now
he saw that a single word had been cut
into the bark in letters two inches high
the word he read there was imperfecta
puzzled he stepped back and then came
that click click click click again and
again he glanced upward to find the
source of the noise but now there was a
man sitting on one of the higher
branches his teeth very white as he
smiled unreadable down from his perch
the man was stocky and very tan with
curly black hair and a thick beard
obviously a working man with broad
shoulders and heavily heavily muscled
forearms in one hand he held a long
silver knife and in the other a pair of
worn tongs it was these two implements
that he was clicking together making a
strange one to rhythm that mimicked
Cades rapid heartbeat what does it mean
Cade heard himself asking placing his
fingertips against the word carved in
the trunk we should bury them said the
man in the tree and his smile grew wider
Cheshire cat like he raised one eyebrow
as though some secret knowledge had
passed between Kaden himself but Cade
remained as confused as ever I don't
understand
Cade pleaded but the man just looked at
him smiling clashing the knife and the
tongs together click-click click-click
awaken ok so that was an exclusive
unpublished bit of a novel that I've
been working on as I said I'm no I don't
know if I'm gonna use that but I kind of
came across it the other day and I'm
like I think I'll put that on the
Halloween show just kind of like a
little bonus thing so hope you guys
enjoyed it let me know what you thought
of it in the comments and I guess since
I'm at the end of the show I'll just do
my little spiel at the end hope you guys
enjoyed this super long super
complicated uh between episode we had a
lot of fun doing it so remember if you
like the show to like share subscribe on
all your social media share with all
your friends and family if you'd like to
financially support the show of course
you can go to our patreon page which is
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast or
you can go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast wordpress.com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
paypal account we have three shows a
week going now obviously the regular
episodes come out every Tuesday we also
have our movie rush
effectives which usually old movies that
comes out on Friday and we also have our
newest show called matinee which comes
out on Sundays that's us reviewing the
three new movies that we've seen in the
theater the previous week so check those
out if you haven't already also check
out our azazel store at zazzle.com slash
13 o'clock podcasts we have like a bunch
of shirts and a tote bag that you may
purchase if you wish to and that will do
it for our super spectacular Halloween
special we will see you guys next time
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]